um
uh Craig Ramon said that uh Gwyneth
Paltrow never talked with anyone at the
scene there's of course disputed
testimony that she swore at the
at Terry at the scene
in either case it shows negligence
afterwards uh because uh it delayed the
the summoning of ski patrol because uh
uh Craig Ramon said he was shocked or
stunned that
what's going on here and then
next thing you know everyone leaves and
he's there alone with Craig with Terry
Sanderson
pointed out by the
defendant in their briefing what's the
evidence that that delay in treatment
and we get this in you know a medical
malpractice case where there's an
allegation that the diagnosis was
delayed negligently and there always has
to be medical evidence
to support damages during that delay
period
the delay well there was what were your
clients damages during if it was delayed
what were your clients damages one
dollar your honor worth of Damages he
was frightened there's evidence from
Craig Ramon that he was frightened the
client the Craig Terry Sanderson
testified he was frightened and uh that
added to his
mental anguish
compounding his mental health injuries
but but right doesn't support a
negligence claim does it
uh I it may just be worth one dollar or
more but no but my question is it does
support a negligence claim isn't that
what negligent inflicts of emotional
distress claim is all about whether
fright can be recovered and that has
already been evaluated by the court and
it hasn't but then we're focusing not on
nied we're focusing on the delay in
treatment the delay in summoning this
Ski Patrol
and but the only damage that you can
point to is Freight
well there's fright and the delay in the
and um
uh the fact that let me ask you the
secondary question I'd like you to
comment on can she recover for that
anyway
can he or she
cancer client recover for that that
fright or I you know you're I assume
under the jury instruction you refer
that would be what that would be mental
anguish
yes under that non-economic damages jury
instruction so can you recover for that
anyway what does this give you this post
accident conduct give you that you don't
already have in comparison to the
permanent brain injury
it doesn't it's small but it gives us
additional uh damage that continues
afterwards because and why can't you
argue that damage anyway no we can and
but it's
it's it seems like the defense wants to
cut off all evidence because of the
motion for summary judgment on negligent
infliction of emotional distress but
that that only says that claim is gone
which has a different standard than
normal negative correct so we're arguing
that
standard negligence
applies here for what happened after the
crashes and uh we also have the
violation of the skiers code and the
Summit County ordinance the safety which
requires that the defendant stay on the
scene to
summon help
give out names
the evidence at trial shows that Terry
Sanderson uh
was knocked out and didn't know what
happened and Whitney Smith did not
believe Craig Ramon saying hey it was
Gwyneth Paltrow and uh so uh his
his what happened was he was
continued to be frightened even up until
Whitney Smith took him down in the
toboggan and maybe at the ski first aid
station
Excuse Me Miss um
Whitney Smith the patroller
took care of Terry and Craig Ramon had
said it so many times finally it dawned
on Terry that he
that no it wasn't me and he cut he could
relax because of that ongoing
um
negligence
delayed the treatment Whitney Smith was
not able to properly assess Terry and
properly investigate this properly
do the things that a patroller would
normally do if if Miss Paltrow had hung
around
so the damage is uh I I think it's I'm
not saying it's as big as the main
injury which is the brain injury uh it's
not but the broken ribs were causing
pain Terry was uh frightful about what
had just happened to him he's waking up
from unconsciousness that there's clear
testimony to all of that Greg Ramon says
that Terry Sanderson says that Craig
Ramon confirms it even uh
Whitney Smith confirms the
disorientation and even on the log of
the ski patrol it says disorientation my
question still though is I I agree with
all of that
my question still is though if I grant a
direct and verdict as to liability on
post on these allegations of
post-accident failure to give name and
address failure to render Aid if I grant
a directed verdict on those two things
um Why can't your clients still recover
for all of that fright
for all of that all of that delay
I mean
isn't that something that you can still
argue under yes we definitely agree with
you on that in your honor so so what
what does it get what does it give you I
guess this post
accident I don't ask for emissions I
don't think it requires a special
instruction I think it's just the
standard negligence uh just like let's
say there's a car crash and the Crash
creates an injury
I'm sorry I forgot to mention this uh we
got this was filed at 9 30 last night
um Sam Goldstein testified right there
that this delay and denial and
caused Terry to suffer additional
psychological uh as well as not
neuropsychological not brain damage but
psychological or psychiatric injury to
this day where Terry is upset I'm more
than upset but uh Stan Sam Goldstein the
neuropsychologist testified that this
pattern has
caused Terry to continue to suffer
damages it's not uh brain damage per se
but it's emotional or um psychiatric or
psychological trauma not neuropsych and
Sam Goldstein who's also a psychologist
testified to that and that it's ongoing
to this day on this witness stand right
here
and we don't want to
compare it to the brain injury but all
combined it's all those factors combine
to support Terry's damage claim for
negligence and we just think that to
artificially cut it off
at oh at the end of the impact and When
Miss Paltrow bounces off Terry and
slides off and tears face down as the
testimony of Craig Ramon confirms
that that that's not the end of the
story the story continues on and has
affected Terry to this day at least
psychologically and Sam Goldstein
confirms that
um let me get this straight about so I
understand the failure to render Aid
aspect and are you relying on the
ordinance for that both the Ordnance and
the ski code but it's not just the
failure to render Aid it's also the okay
go ahead and then the second question is
failing to give name and address
how do you attach that to any damage
well that's like in the car crash and
someone's dazed
concussion and it may not be a hit and
run it may be something less they they
stayed and they said are you okay and if
we assume they're correct but they get
up and Craig Ramon says Gwyneth Paltrow
didn't say anything and they just get up
and then they drive away
are you relying on the ordinance for the
name and address thing too both of them
but also just common sense it could be a
sidewalk
it could be a sidewalk your honor you're
relying on both of them you said both
both the ski ordinance and the skiers
code does the skier code say that you
need to give your name and address uh
the skier's code yes what's that exhibit
plaintiff's exhibit well it was
testified to by Eric Christensen and and
uh I Believe by Paul Bogger yesterday
that there's a skiers code and it's also
testified to uh
by it's just kind of it's standard like
uh Mr Sorenson do you have the the
plaintiff's exhibit for that skier code
here it is it's 37.
doesn't talk about giving your name and
address if there's an impact so I the
only the only evidence that I'm aware of
for establishing that is possible
evidence of negligence is the is the
ordinance
I think the ordinance but also in the
says that they're to give it to a Deer
Valley employee and she already had done
that before she even started that day
the Deer Valley employee employs the the
ski instructors knew who she was and
right had our contact information but we
had a clear testimony is the ski
instructor Christensen did not give her
information that doesn't require that
the ordinance or the skiers code either
one
the ordinance says that better to give
it to a Deer Valley employee
if there's an if there's an accident am
I reading that right
I think that's I think that's exhibit
38.
yeah at the very end of the of this of
the Summit County Reckless skiing
ordinance the last phrase
if it is necessary to secure aid for a
person injured in the Collision the
person securing such Aid shall give his
name and address as required here and
after such Aid is secured him before
leaving the ski area
that's uh and who's the person securing
such Aid
I think that's the person that reported
it right
wouldn't that be Mr Ramon
it says any skier above the first part
of that full sentence of part C
ier's duty to notify operator or
employee an event of collision
any skier involved in a collision with
another skier a person in which injury
results shall give his name and address
to an employee of the ski area operator
or a member of the ski patrol and that's
my point
didn't she do that isn't it Undisputed
that she gave that information to a ski
area operator working on the incident
report
when my clients sought that information
it wasn't listed on in fact it was
Whited out that on the information he
got so he had no way to contact her and
he had to spend additional effort
psychological effort that was harmful to
him as per Dr Goldstein this continuous
denial and and obstruction
added to his
torment and damages now you could say
it's wrong it's small but Dr Goldstein
said it was significant enough that he
reported on it and said Terry Sanderson
was still suffering from it five years
later
you understand the argument now
Mr Owens any follow-up
none of us wants to confuse the jury
they understand this is a negligence
claim
but even I'm confused on this idea of
she did something negligently after the
fact
there's been no evidence no expert
testimony or otherwise that the delay
caused any harm whatsoever
so goldstein's testimony as I recall
it was Eric christensen's yelling
not Gwyneth Paltrow's not yelling when
he described uh
Mr Sanderson
observing and hearing a man screaming in
his face Eric Christensen
um
that's disputed by Mr Christensen but
even if it's assuming it's to be true
that has nothing to do with Gwyneth
Paltrow's personal information
what about the argument that that the
difficulties encountered later in
figuring out who this was and
establishing
you know the correct information from
the reporting caused additional I guess
anguish on the part of Mr Sanderson so
Steve Graf the Deer Valley head of
operations reported receiving
two contacts from the patient
sorry from Sanderson and that he
responded and relayed
gwyneth's proper information I realize
that's your evidence the defendant's
evidence but what about the plaintiff's
evidence could the jury not make some
conclusions based on that that are
reasonable so
what do we know is by six hours he knew
the person's name and actually thought
it was cool
I've been I'm I'm famous
and I think the Undisputed testimony is
that
the ski instructor told
Ramone
your buddy just took out Gwyneth Paltrow
now
if sanderson's
testimony is to believe he wasn't in his
best state
to receive an address or anything it was
appropriate to talk to his friend his
friend Craig Ramon's right there
that was Gwyneth Paltrow you can Google
Gwyneth Paltrow and get an address for
her her work
they had that together then they were
texting on their uh
their Meet Up group like Gwyneth Paltrow
did this
so they had information right away the
mental distress and things I think as
you said they can talk about that the
aftermath but not her actions she didn't
have negligent actions by uh
I think in all all reports
Terry said I'm okay
what about Terry's testimony and Mr
Goldstein I guess that's what I'm
focusing their evidence Goldstein Terry
says that he was frightened by the fact
that he was just left there yes and and
Dr Goldstein substantiates that and
substantiates that it was a continuing
concern Goldstein and I took it all to
mean Christensen he
Terry looked up he saw a Deer Valley
person in a green outfit and he said oh
good there's someone here to help me and
then when
this the green Deer Valley guys skied
away which is contrary to Eric
christensen's testimony that he was the
last on the scene but let's let's
presume sanderson's testimonies correct
he felt abandoned he didn't say I felt
abandoned that gweneth left I don't
remember that testimony so I think
they're conflating the two uh it's
probably a good thing that Gwyneth
didn't stay she was pretty mad
uh
she got all clear from Christensen he's
okay they observed no unconsciousness by
the way he's on his feet
ski patrol people everything okay
everything's okay
and then you can leave
the abandonment came from the ski
employee and that was for keep in mind a
few minutes because a few minutes later
downhill
I'm not okay okay different story but
I'm not okay
let's flag the patroller Whitney's there
and he's
so we really are talking about a couple
minutes
and it wasn't from the Gwyneth
abandonment it was from the ski
patroller he felt like the ski patroller
had bullied him and had abandoned him
he never said I felt a band about hurt
and Abandoned and frustrated that the
skier whose name they now knew
had left
that's all thank you all right
thank you
well I don't want to delay the uh the
jury
um
let me just rule on these motions so as
to the directed motion on on the
negligence claim the general negligence
claim for the accident itself the Court
denies the motion for the reasons that
in the evidence that were marshaled by
Mr Bueller as to the post accident
conduct it's a little more difficult and
it's also Complicated by the fact that
there was a negligent infliction of
emotional distress claim that was
dismissed and essentially what the
plaintiff is claiming is related to the
post-conduct post-action conduct is in
the nature of
uh
of
of emotional distress or emotional
or mental suffering the Fright
associated with being
left alone and the Fright associated
with
failure to give name and address let me
just address that part first so I don't
think there's any evidence that the jury
could decide that
that Miss Paltrow did not give her name
and address to an employee of the ski
area operator or a member of the ski
patrol before leaving the vicinity she
did do that
so I don't believe that she violated her
do any Duty that might be imposed by the
by the ordinance and that's the only
place that there's any evidence that
requires her to give her name and
address at the scene of an accident
and so that post conduct I think is out
as to the duty to render Aid I think
that they're still that there is an
issue of fact and there is evidence that
the jury could decide that the that the
duty to render Aid was not followed
um
the
and I'm relying on the plaintiff's
testimony himself as well as that of Sam
Goldstein and Mr Ramon
I think that I acknowledge that that The
Testament that the testimony on this
issue was primarily directed at the Deer
Valley employee and the fact that they
abandoned allegedly abandoned the
plaintiff at the scene
but I think that there's enough
testimony from both the plaintiff Mr
Ramon and then also from Sam Goldstein
to also include the defendant herself
um
and I'm not commenting at all on any of
the evidence that the defendants have
presented on that issue and only focused
on what the plaintiff
presented because I'm required to do
that and I'm also required to
um
grant them any reasonable inferences
from that evidence that the jury might
be able to make
so so that portion of the
motion is denied
I guess what that will leave for for us
is to determine how to read
that ordinance in terms of a jury
instruction so we still have have that
to resolve after we spoke last night
any questions or clarifications
okay why don't we just take a short
break then and we'll return with the
jury thank you are there any other
preliminary issues
okay
foreign
could you let the lawyers know the jury
is on the way
good morning
we're just waiting on a few more parties
so it'll just be a moment
there was no snow this morning but I
understand we may get some later so
so let the record reflect that all
parties and Council are present the jury
is present
and I realized we took a few Witnesses
out of order
but at this point does the plane of rest
its case yes sure okay
are you ready to call your next witness
yes your honor we called Dr black our
neuroradiology expert thank you
Mr Black right up here
or Dr Black do you swear that the
testimony you are about to give of the
case now before the court will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth shall help you God yes
yes thank you good morning
come have a seat
once you get situated if you can State
your full name and spell it
my name is Carl Milton black
c-a-r-l m-i-l-t-o-n-b-l-a-c-k
thanks for being here with us Dr Black
Let's uh Begin by just asking you what
your role is in this case
I was asked to review Imaging related to
this case
between the years of 2009 through 2021
and what expertise do you have that
allows you to opine on Imaging of brain
scans I'm a fellowship-trained
neuroradiologist I also have Fellowship
training in vascular and intervention
Audiology and I'm double board certified
by the American Board of radiology in
neuroradiology and vascular and
Interventional Radiology
is there anything about that experience
and training that is relevant to your
opinions in this case
yes I have expertise in analyzing
Imaging of the brain
okay
and um
let's just go over very quickly
um
the images that you reviewed uh what
maybe give us the type of image and then
the the years
of those images were taken
the Imaging consisted mainly of CT
Doppler and MRI
the range of years dated back to Imaging
performed at the Veterans Administration
Hospital in 2009 and then subsequently
Imaging again at the veteran
administration in 2016 Imogene performed
at Cog FX in 2017 and subsequent Imaging
performed in 2021 at Blue Rock medical
or Riverwoods and
does that mean that you reviewed Imaging
both before the ski accident and after
the ski accident yes
in your review of The Imaging did you
see any evidence of traumatic brain
injury after the accident no
did you see any image any evidence in
the Imaging before the accident that
might be consistent with Mr sanderson's
post accident symptoms
yes and we'll talk about the specifics
of those
um are you also
um
familiar with Dr Gibby's opinions in
this case as the jury will recall Dr
Wendell Gibby is plaintiff's Radiology
expert are you aware of that
I have reviewed the reports that were
provided by Dr Gibby on Imaging that he
performed in 2021 I've also reviewed his
deposition that he provided to the
court and so you're familiar with his
opinions in this case
as reflected in his reports in his
deposition yes yeah
um
in addition to the Imaging itself did
you read the reports that were created
by the radiologist who took that Imaging
yes
and and we'll look at those reports in
detail I just want to make it clear that
what you've reviewed do you feel like
you've reviewed everything you needed to
to assess this Imaging that you've
described yes I've reviewed both the
Imaging itself and the reports
associated with each of those studies
Okay so
I want to start with
an exhibit the plaintiff or the jury has
already seen
it's a
exhibit to Dr Gibby's deposition I
believe you've seen this I'll show it
and for reference I know it we marked it
as one of plaintiff's exhibits and I'm
forgetting the number now I just had it
in my head do you guys recall
this one right here we added it to the
end I apologize I had it in my mind and
now I've forgot
well while they're looking that up Dr
Black
have you seen this image before I have
and what is it
this is a axial Imaging from axial image
from an MRI performed at Cog FX
on October 18 2017 specifically it's a
flare T2 sequence and do you understand
Cog FX or cognitive FX to be Dr Fong's
Clinic that's my understanding okay just
to help the jury they have heard from Dr
Kong so an MRI was taken at Dr Fong's
Clinic were those green arrows part of
the MRI initially
no those were
I believe placed by Dr Gibby during his
deposition okay and what do you
understand those uh
um to mean what did Dr Gibby put those
arrows there for
those those arrows are pointing to what
he's terming white matter disease
and what is white matter disease
white matter disease reflects
scarring in the brain and often it
occurs around the ventricles that you
see here
in the deposition Dr Gibby's Point using
these arrows to point to areas where
he's suspected that these May relate to
trauma I see and I'm noting that uh
Peter Jensen on my team has just noted
that this is plaintiff exhibit 31 I
believe for the record
okay so
um those same uh points that we're
looking at with the green arrows in in
your understanding of Dr Gibby's
opinions is he pointing to those as
evidence of post-collision problems for
Mr Sanderson
that's what he indicates in his
deposition yes but in your review of the
prior Imaging do those same findings
show up
if you review The Imaging from 2009 at
which time Mr Sanderson had a
comprehensive
Imaging workup that included Imaging of
his brain as well as the blood vessels
that supply his brain these findings
were present in 2009
I see and I believe you've prepared some
images that you took you've taken from
the prior
prior to the accident images and post
accident images and noted those and is
that correct that's correct we'll show
this to the jury in just a second but
what I want to do while we have this one
up is give you a pointer and have you
point to other findings that you see in
this
MRI from 2017 is that okay will that
help you explain to the your opinions
about this image yeah if it's I'm happy
to do that okay oh bring it to you may I
approach your honor
okay Dr Black so
you've talked about the green arrows
what other findings do you see here
oh yeah thank you
does that work
this study does show Imaging Imaging
Imaging that was or findings that were
demonstrated over a decade of Imaging in
this case dating back to 2009 one of
them was a mild degree of cortical
volume loss or loss of brain volume the
other was in this area here these are
the ventricles and it showed as
disproportionate enlargement of the
ventricles relative to the amount of
tissue loss in the gray matter and
overall brain volume
the findings around the ventricles these
white areas are very typical of what's
called microvascular disease
where
brain matter around the ventricles is
deprived of oxygen over a long period of
time and that results in gliosis or
scarring this pattern is really is very
typical of what we call microvascular
ischemic white matter disease and that
was present in 2009. and did I hear you
correctly earlier do you have
specialized training in those particular
findings beyond what a typical
radiologist might have
my fellowship training and experience in
neurodiology and and consistently
reading brain MRI gives me expertise in
looking at these at looking at these
findings which we often see on a regular
basis
I see so this is a post ski Collision
image correct this particular sequence
is from 2019. my understanding is the
accident occurred in 2016. yeah and I
think you said 19 but you pointed to 27
I'm sorry
2017. yes correct yes and
um so
you said earlier I believe that the same
findings you're pointing to again not
just Dr Gibby's findings with the green
arrows but the other ones you just
talked about they're in the pre-accident
images is that right yes my review of
The Imaging that was done at the
Veterans Administration Hospital in 2009
it shows these in these similar findings
and in the reports that were provided by
The neuroradiologists Who read the
Imaging at that time they describe these
findings right okay so let's
um maybe have you sit down again and
I'll pull up those slides that you made
thank you
so this is defendants exhibit 101 a
through uh
I believe it's a through f
and um your honor I moved to admit this
as a demonstrative exhibit
no objection exhibit defense exhibit 101
a through f is received for
demonstrative purposes
thank you your honor so Dr Black do you
recognize this slide
yes this slide is also a what's called a
flare sequence a T2 flare sequence
done in what's called an axial plane
which just means the the orientation the
way the image was acquired through the
brain
this image was acquired in March of 2009
at the Veterans Administration hospital
so that's before the accident correct
yes yeah and again when I say accident I
mean the ski Collision in 2016. yes and
it's not terribly easy to see but I can
call it out here
there's a little arrow do you recognize
that I put that Arrow there yes okay and
what does it point to that Arrow points
to white matter disease is similar to
what Dr Gibby had pointed out in the
Imaging from 2017 right okay so
in other words that prior or this is a
prior finding that's the same uh as the
post-accident finding Dr Gibby saw
yes about eight years earlier okay got
it and what is this finding associated
with
again most commonly we see this with
what we term microvasculars can make
white matter disease
there are predisposing risk factors for
this we're in some patients that may be
accelerated
but it's typically a process that's due
to
pathology or abnormalities in the in the
very small some of the smallest blood
vessels that supply the brain
particularly around the ventricles
then I'll go to the next one which is
101b
and again call out a section here at the
bottom there's kind of a faint red arrow
again did you put that there and why'd
you put that there
because it again shows the same pattern
of white matter disease that was
demonstrated on MRI of 2017. okay so
again a finding before the accident that
was there also after the accident that's
correct and what's this finding
associated with the exact same
description got it Okay then if we move
to
101 C there's yet another red arrow I
take it you put that there yes and uh is
it is it again to point out that Dr
Gibby's finding a post-accident problems
in that area preceded the accident yes
accounting for technical differences
away in the plane of the way this exam
was acquired from 2009 to 2017 these
findings are identical right got it okay
and they're also associated with the
same things you've described already
most likely microvascular disease and
that's when he underwent his
comprehensive Imaging work up at the VA
hospital in 2009 it was also attributed
to vascular disease at that time okay
so
number uh defense exhibit 101 d e is
like your same version of that 2017
image that Dr Gibby looked at correct
and it has those same spots so just use
the laser here that again these arrows
are kind of faint on my copy I apologize
but they're pointing to those same
points we've just looked at previously
is that right yes okay and then if we go
to
the next
image this is a new image we haven't
looked at correct correct and this one's
from 2021
as it's marked
where was this image taken do you recall
yes this image was
obtained at uh
Blue Rock medical or Riverwoods Imaging
which Dr Gibby owns and
this is a the same sequence that we've
shown before as far as how it is
technically obtained by MRI
same slice got it and again we have some
arrows
correct correct and those are your
arrows yes and they're showing I take it
the same the this process or some
findings that you've seen in the 2009
and then 2017 images that's correct so
you're you're seeing this same condition
in the brain for many years both before
the accident and after it over an
11-year period of a similar pattern of
white matter disease yes
and then if we go to the next image
101f we call out that upper left
quadrant arrow and again I believe you
put that there correct and kind of for
the same reasons to show these
conditions persist from 2009 before the
accident to this image in 2021 that's
correct
okay thank you
um
let's see so
uh that would be the next one okay uh
which I I haven't referenced but if if
there's no objection that's just the
next bit of the slides no objection okay
what does that mean can you move that
see let's just just let us see it before
that sure yes in your heart
is that 101 f
so this is 101f on the screen and then
what Steve has put here is 101 G
defense exhibit 101 G is that also for
demonstrative purposes yes your honor
C for demonstrative purposes
Okay so
um Dr Black you've used various medical
terminology that we might not all be
familiar with mycovascular disease for
example can you give us a sense of what
in late persons terms what these sorts
of findings are correlated with how they
impact a person
sure
the microvascular disease itself is a
term that's used to describe micro just
being very small and then vascular the
blood vessels
that when these blood vessels over time
become diseased which happens in a broad
section of the population and some
people it's accelerated due to
underlying high blood pressure or
perhaps other diseases of the blood
blood vessels then you start to see
scarring around initially around the
ventricles these are unlike large
Strokes that may affect the cortex of
the brain these are smaller areas where
the blood blood vessels are compromised
and it results in
scarring of the tissue around the
ventricles and that's why we call it
white matter disease
the other Imaging in 2009 from the
Veterans Administration with the CT
angio
specifically looked at the larger blood
vessels that supplied
Mr sanderson's brain and in those images
they found plaque or or hardening of the
arteries in the Carotid bifurcation on
his right side and then also in the
larger blood vessels inside of his brain
near where his retinal arteries come off
or the cavernous carotid arteries and
those also show plaque or
atherosclerosis okay is uh is it
um
too reductive to say that these findings
are an indication of an aging brain
well aging aging can result in this
because we're all deteriorating to some
degree or other every day we live right
but because we have a baseline you can
attribute certain findings if it's
happening at an accelerated level given
someone's age then it might indicate
there's underlying medical problems
um the other finding that was present is
that that was consistently present was
the enlargement of the ventricles which
on all images seem to be
disproportionate or out of the
proportion to the amount of atrophy of
the brain
um at several in several reports there
was a suggestion of a diagnosis of
normal pressure hydrocephalus and in
fact in if you go to the
the image
let's see
that uh maybe the 2000 there's a well
2021 we don't have it on here there is
there's an image he showed that shows
What's called transependable edema
and that's fluid that leaks through the
the site of the ventricle due to build
pressure buildup in The ventricle and
that's a supporting finding from an
Imaging perspective of normal pressure
hydrocephalus obviously that has to be
correlated to someone's clinical
presentation and symptoms and that's
where a neurologist would play an
important role in that I see and just
for I think the jury has heard about
this term multiple times but let's spend
just a moment from your perspective
defining what normal pressure
hydrocephalus is
normal normal pressure hydrocephalus is
is basically an imbalance of the way
fluid's managed within the the
ventricular system of the brain and it
can result in confusion or unsteadiness
of gait and when it's clinically
applicable but we
from an Imaging perspective that
diagnosis suggested when the ventricles
seem to be disproportionately enlarged
relative to the brain volume itself so
from an Imaging perspective there was
strong indication that Mr Sanderson had
normal pressure hydrocephalus it was
suggested in
every brain study he's had since 2009
and is it a progressive condition in
other words does it get worse with time
yes it can
and then
um I'm going to go to another image that
or another report a document that the
jury has already seen this one we looked
at with Dr Gibby this is his report from
March 3rd 2021 do you remember seeing
this
yes I reviewed this okay uh I believe
it's also part of Gibby's packet and
plaintiff's exhibit 31.
um
what I want to point out I think I
called this out with Dr Gibby I want you
to comment on it there's a part of this
report that says I don't see any sign of
shearing injury do you do you see that
I I see his report yes and do you agree
with that I agree with this report yes
okay and
um what do you understand Dr Gibby's
opinions to be as as cheering injury is
concerned
so this report was performed in on March
3rd 2021 specifically looking for
evidence of brain trauma
so that was the that was the clinical
history provided to Dr Gibby and he was
looking in detail
for any Imaging findings that would
support
a closed head injury with hearing injury
one of those yeah the things that
um Dr Gibby would have been looking for
or that any of us would look for when
we're evaluating a study in a patient
with brain injury would be sharing of
the white matter tracks the these are
very delicate tracks where if there's a
rapid deceleration of the brain those
can Shear when they do share they
deposit little micro hemorrhages that
leave blood products in the brain
specifically iron that's found in
hemoglobin so in another sequence Dr
Gibby would have been looking for any
evidence of iron deposition which he
mentions here pathologic iron deposition
and then the other thing you would look
for is is bruising up the cortex of the
brain the brain does move to some degree
with inside the skull because of the
it's bathed in cerebral spinal fluid
so if there's a rapid deceleration the
the brain cortex can hit up against the
skull and and cause a bruise in some
cases it can result in Hemorrhage but in
other cases it can result in in focal
atrophy at those locations so in this
case none of the Imaging showed a
contusion no Shear injury and no
evidence of pathologic hemorrhage in the
brain
what would you expect to see in a a
person's Imaging after some kind of
traumatic brain injury
well it depends on the severity of
course right in in mild trauma you
nothing okay
and
um what would you what would you just
how would you describe Dr Gibby's
opinions about the evidence of trauma in
his uh Mr sanderson's post collision and
imaging
in Dr Gibby's report where he
specifically was looking for evidence of
trauma he emphatically states there is
no evidence of post-traumatic brain
injury in his report
now it is interesting because it
um contradicts to some degree
his description in his deposition
the um how does it contradict that well
um Dr Gibby mentions that in in his
deposition that the white matter disease
that we've reviewed is very typical of
Shear injury or or pathologic brain
injury
but yet in his own report of the Imaging
which was performed at his Center which
is is identical to the findings in 2017
where he was offering that opinion his
deposition
he emphatically states that there is no
evidence of post-traumatic brain injury
objection the state's prior testimony
overruled the jury will have to recall
the testimony
Mr Dr Black do you see on this report
any indication that this image was
compared to Prior images
know the is that common to do when you
do a report you compare it to Prior
images
there were
three Imaging studies done after the
accident one was a CT scan done again at
the veteran Veterans Administration in
2016 which was compared to 2009.
the Imaging that was performed in 2017
and and 2021 make no reference of
comparison dating back to 2009 so I
presume those images were not available
to them was is that a problem uh is that
lead to any limitations of a study if
you don't look back at the prior studies
it does limit the way that a neurologist
can interpret an image if you have prior
Imaging it helps put things into context
and can narrow the
differential or the possibilities in in
terms of a diagnosis for example in this
case
knowing that the white matter disease
pre-existed in 2009 is helpful to
exclude that it's a result of Shear
injury from an accident in 2016. so yes
comparison Imaging when it's available
is is of extreme importance so are you
critical of uh Dr Gibby for not doing
that comparison
not necessarily critical those those
images just may not have been available
to him I I think if you offer an opinion
as to causality and you do have Imaging
that's available from
the Veterans Administration and someone
draws a conclusion without Baseline
Imaging taking into account that can
alter someone's conclusion and lead to
an error in their in how they're
discussing why that abnormality exists
and do you believe that sort of error
occurred here with Dr Gibby's opinion I
do I think he was limited by the
unavailability or lack of comparison to
the Imaging that was done in 2009 yes
okay I want to move to another report
this is for that 2017 image we started
with the one with the green arrows that
was taken at Dr Fong's Clinic
it's in plaintiff's exhibit 33 page
eight I don't know that we've shown it
so I'd move to admit it uh
it's plants exhibit 33 page eight eight
and I guess eight and nine there's two
pages
just a report
oh just the Imaging or the report which
one
which one of the plaintiffs or exhibit
33 Fong's packet pages
three was not received
seems like no objection may I publish it
to the jury your honor
no objection exhibit planus exhibit 33
page 8 is received and James do you want
it from start to end or was there just
one no just two pages page eight and
page nine page eight and page nine are
received yeah this is again the report
connected to the image that we looked at
first taken at Dr Fong's clinic in 2017.
is that correct Dr Black that's correct
and I want to point to I guess we should
first ask the questions we were just
asking about Dr Gibby do you see any
comparison here no okay so the same uh
points you made about the limitations of
Dr Gibby's report you would say about
this report is that right correct and if
we call out this bottom part that's
called Impressions I'd like for you to
comment on whether you agree with these
I do agree with these Impressions and
will you take us through them in in
layperson's terminology maybe we could
start uh
uh we covered some parts of the
ventricles you feel like you've you've
explained that
well I I think we can let me just
emphasize one another perspective go
ahead of the ventricles also I think
it's important to note that the context
of this study being acquired was
specifically with the intent to look for
any evidence of closed head injury or
significant brain trauma and so there
are negatives
that are pointed out by the radiologist
who interpreted this exam that did not
exist like Hemorrhage in the brain or or
evidence of of a contusion so there are
pertinent negatives even with the strong
bias of looking for those because of the
history
so just to make sure I'm understanding
you that when you talk about bias you're
just saying going into this image they
heard a history of traumatic brain
injury concussion so they're actually
they're
apprised at the possibility of various
findings that might be associated with
that and they want to find them they're
they're correct that's that's correct
Foundation sustained for leading
so um
maybe just comment on uh bias again
because that term is used in various
ways
um what do you mean when you talk about
bias in these when I'm referring to bias
I'm talking professionally when we
interpret an exam the clinical context
of that exam or why that exam is being
obtained is important to us if somebody
has an infection or if somebody's has a
brain tumor then we we understand that
and we're looking for various findings
that would support that in this case if
somebody has known trauma then that
would alert the radiologist to look for
certain findings so in the case of the
MRI performed in 2017 and the one
performed in 2021 there would be a
an alert to look for findings related to
trauma so it's so the negatives the
pertinent negatives in the exam from
2017 just like the one that was
performed in 2021 would
um rule out Imaging evidence of
significant head trauma yeah so in other
words they're looking for trauma but
they they did not find it yes
okay so let's go to these findings again
here in number two there's normal
pressure hydrocephalus we've talked
about that but there are a couple other
things
um normal aging brain Alzheimer's
dementia
subcortical arterial sclerotic
encephalopathy multi-infared dementia
did I read all that correctly you did
and those are some big words can you
comment on those how did you understand
what what these are doing in this report
well the some of these are clinical
descriptors which would require a
neurologist to make a correlation by
examining that patient because we
Imaging can show a lot of things that
don't necessarily manifest in someone
clinically
so it's important to always take it into
clinical context the one description
here that actually reflects underlying
pathology would be the arterial
sclerotic encephalopathy that's just a
big word for diseases of the blood
vessels specifically plaque or hardening
of the arteries
the comprehensive workup that was done
at the Veterans Administration in 2009
did show evidence of vascular disease at
that time in the carotid arteries in the
neck and also in the brain and at that
time the white matter disease which
again was present over a decade later
was attributed to vascular's disease
did you see any evidence in the Imaging
that correlates with vision problems
there was mention of it with the
functional MRI
but that is beyond my expertise okay you
can leave that to neurologists to speak
to somebody else somebody has some
expertise in functional Imaging okay
um
Okay so
you can take this down I think
um
did you note anything in the well let me
ask first are you aware that Dr Gibby
actually met with Mr Sanderson
I'm aware of that and is there anything
about that meeting that has any bearing
on your opinions today
the only bearing I would have is that Dr
Gibby makes mention in his
report that he had told Mr Sanderson
that it's possible you could go through
all of this work up and not find any
evidence of post-traumatic brain injury
and why would that be significant to you
simply because the obviously the intent
of that workup was to
specifically look for evidence of brain
injury
I believe the juries heard Dr Gibby
uh give an opinion that I I want to see
if you remember and what your comment
might be your response to it might be if
the image is prior to the accident
are similar to The Post accident Imaging
you know in other words if the Imaging
prior showed things that were
post-accident
um
would
um would that mean that you you cannot
say the prior findings were caused by
the accident objection leading the
state's prior testimony
as to Leading sustained okay so uh do
you do you recall Dr Gibby giving an
opinion that if the PO the pre-accident
findings are are sorry the post accident
findings are found in the pre-accident
Imaging that you could not say that the
post accident Imaging was caused by the
accident injection leading stand
okay
um
what do you recall Dr Gibby saying about
the relationship between the pre-exit
and imaging and the post accident
Imaging
my opinion on that would be based on his
deposition if you'd like I can read two
areas of his deposition that I think
answer your question sure go ahead so
sustained okay so uh let's just ask you
this question do you have any opinions
about whether the post accident Imaging
findings
can be attributed to from an Imaging
perspective
Collision the ski Collision projection
leading overruled
we asked that again yes
do you have any opinions about whether
the post accident Imaging findings
can be attributed to the Collision
yes what is that opinion
that those findings predate the accident
and date back to at least 2009 as
confirmed by a comprehensive Imaging
workup of mistress Henderson's brain
performed at the veterans have been
Administration Hospital
um
I mean so do you do you believe those
pre-accident uh sorry post taxes and I
apologize that I keep missing messing
this up you you believe that those
post-accident Imaging findings are in
any way related to the Collision
and what was the reason for that 2009
workup to your knowledge
um unfortunately
um Mr Sanderson had suffered a retinal
artery occlusion a central retinal
reclusion
that resulted in in blindness in one eye
and so he was undergoing a workup for
risk factors that would relate to that
okay and
um
do you do you know any of the people
that have done any of his Imaging
I'm familiar with them yes yeah and so
that 2009 workup or do you know the
people that did that workout yes and do
you trust uh the findings that they came
to they're very experienced in a
well-trained yes okay great that's all
the questions I have for now thank you
thank you
thank you Mr Egan
sister Bueller
I'm going to start a at the end
you're not an eye doctor are you I'm not
and you said the Imaging
from the um
retinal artery occlusion
means blindness in the eye does that
mean total blindness that's beyond my
expertise and I'm not familiar enough
with his clinical condition to comment
on that so your term blindness is
probably a little broad broad I only
gained that from the histories that were
provided with his Imaging studies okay
so uh he may still have some Vision in
his eye even though absolutely okay
so I just wanted to point that out
let's see uh
true you were a partner of Dr Wendell
Gibby's yes
and how long ago was that it's been
probably over 10 years okay
and uh
so you know his work correct correct
um
you're not critical of his work in
general are you no not at all okay
you never conducted an exam of the
client Terry Sanderson no
you understand there was a sudden change
after this ski crash in Terry
sanderson's
condition brain health
from my review of the records that's my
understanding
you understand that through you read
before and after Witnesses who confirmed
there was a sudden change after the
Collision correct
would you mind asking that again did you
read before and after witness testimony
uh
you didn't so you didn't read
there's a before and after witness
testimony important to understanding
someone's uh brain injury I think it's
very important but it was beyond the
scope of what I was to do I concentrated
only on his Imaging okay so you didn't
have the before and after information
that would
improve the diagnosis that you might
or the opinions you might give today in
court to this jury
I understood that with respect to the
Imaging we were looking for evidence of
brain trauma as would manifest on
Imaging and so that's where I
concentrated my focus
well you said that um
mtbi
may not be shown on an MRI true
the a mild brain injury yes correct okay
so Dr Sanderson could have a brain
injury
mild traumatic brain injury and not be
shown up on Imaging right that's correct
now the two the 2009 Imaging it was
asymptomatic true
um again I don't understand
I'm not a
I'm not the clinician who expanded him
at that time and I can only look at his
Imaging in the context of the
information so I I don't feel qualified
to answer your question
thank you
um
so from the Imaging from 2009 2017 2021
there's no change right
very little change
okay
um
Dr Black
no one's given a diagnosis that
that Terry Sanderson has
clinical NPH or normal pressure
hydrocephalus true
I I don't know that for sure
okay
so the mph was not clinically uh
diagnosed by his VA doctors as far as
you know correct as far as I know it was
only suggested well it was suggested in
in most of his Imaging studies but I
don't know what clinical correlation was
made
okay and so clinical correlation means
that uh
specialist at the VA or elsewhere that
understood his
NPH was
showing
symptoms correct that's correct
so you don't need pathological evidence
of
to have a mtbi correct
and when you say pathologically are you
seeing Imaging evidence yes that's
correct
okay so Dr Black Imaging
can show a lot that
um
that hasn't really manifested or shown
up correct
we state that one more time okay Imaging
can show a lot of things that hasn't
shown up in
um
in a clinical setting no yes correct
so
Terry could have these problems that
show up on Imaging
but there there's no
um
symptoms that would affect him from or
stop him from skiing for instance
it's possibly yes okay
and in general
you would prefer to have an actual exam
of the patient
to render your opinions true
um I think that Imaging correlated with
a clinical exam is the correct way to
assess a patient's condition
so you would prefer to have
an exam
correct yes
well I prefer I mean I think they
correlate
the information's
the information is valuable in both
circumstances but optimally in decision
making you want both types of
information
so your opinions
are not as strong as they would be
without this exam right
without a clinical exam
there there's my opinions are certainly
limited to his Imaging
oh thank you you bet
thank you Mr Bueller
Mr Egan
Dr Black you were asked about before and
after Witnesses
of family members people close to Mr
Sanderson before and after the accident
I'm not sure I understood that question
but okay well my question is just
whether
opinions from such Witnesses would
affect your read of the objective
findings in the images no they would not
and what about if you actually met with
Mr Sanderson would that change the
objective findings in the images no
because I would defer to a neurologist
or a neuropsychologist
I'm someone who with that kind of
expertise to evaluate Mr Sanderson my
area of expertise is in brain Imaging do
you typically evaluate patients when you
read their Imaging with regard to brain
Imaging no and then after
um
see I I guess we did we did show one of
these boards but you didn't get to see
it I want to make sure you see it so the
jury knows that you
okay
this is 101 G and these are the same are
these the same images we were looking at
on the screen
yes and they show that before there was
a finding that was also after the
Collision is that right correct Okay so
I think the jury's already seen this and
then we also have
two more boards which we didn't show
your honor I moved to admit 101 H and
101 I for demonstrative purposes
no objection the defense exhibit 101 H
and 101i or just plaintiff's exhibits
the
exhibits are received for demonstrative
purposes so I'll show you first Dr Black
is this the same idea as the board we
just saw Yes okay just with different
findings yes okay and then that was
one-on-one age
overruled and
his 101 I
and it's the same same idea yes okay so
I just showed the jury 101 age
101 I
and then my last question for you
Dr Black is whether after questioning
from Mr Bueller you have your opinions
about these objective findings you've
been discussing on the Imaging changed
they have not okay thank you
earlier you
said you preferred to have objective
findings from a neurologist or
neuropsychologist correct
for clinical correlation absolutely yeah
for clinical correlation
would you defer to someone like Dr
Goldstein
I don't know him so that name doesn't
mean anything to me he's a
neuropsychologist who testified in this
trial
you didn't know that
no
so Dr Goldstein
provided clinical correlation and that
would help your opinions if you had that
true
I'm sure if somebody has expertise
clinically that I don't have
but it doesn't change how I interpret
the images or or my view of these
findings so your opinions are limited to
your
uh
review of the images and not the
clinical findings true correct thank you
history again
you may be excused thank you
witness or take a brief break is this
witness going to take a bit bro Robert
host
cash sorry and
I would think uh
I could be on and off in a half hour I
think
okay why don't we go ahead and take a
break because there will be
cross-examination I'm sure
we'll take a recess now
thank you
you ready for the jury
once you let them know whenever they're
done
they're still cycling through I think
yes
so maybe just have them hold at the door
sure
yeah they're still uh take they're still
doing a few things Mr Sykes
we'll have to have you be sworn in why
don't you take a seat out in the out in
the gallery
foreign
worked on the chair I think the chair is
in good shape now
okay whenever the jury is ready we're
ready
yes
they're not quite ready either so
thank you
Mr Owens you may call your next Witness
Robert Hesh
to the stand
thank you
Dr Hesh if you could come right up here
to the clerk and be sworn in
case now before the court will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth shall help you God
thank you
good morning
if you could start by stating your full
name and spell it out for us
my name is Robert Hesh
r-o-b-e-r-t-h-o-e-s-c-h
doctor nice to see you what what uh what
city do you live in absolutely
I'm going to take this off I do have a
cold but
um
what's your current position
I'm currently the chief medical officer
for Intermountain Healthcare in Utah and
Idaho
is that mean the top MD for all of
Intermountain Healthcare
in Utah and Idaho
okay uh you're pretty young are you how
old are you
when I hired on you on this case you
were not you didn't have such a
prestigious title did you no I did not
what were you
I was a neurologist at Intermountain
Medical Center and the uh the leader of
our neurosciences program at
Intermountain
good for you
um
to be clear you are not here on behalf
of Intermountain Healthcare is that
right correct my opinions are my own
thank you
all right
um
just undergrad where was that briefly
undergrad University of Maryland College
Park and what subject
cell and molecular biology and genetics
what a nerd
I am a neurologist
kidding
poli-size the nerd thing all right good
for you and then your md degree was
where University of Maryland in
Baltimore and uh what did you choose to
specialize in neurology okay and how
many years so four years undergrad four
years med school then how many more
years
well then I did a PhD for four years as
well in that time and then went across
town to Hopkins for my neurology
residency so that was another four years
what a nerd
all right four years in post I would
doctorate what's that in
neurology okay and and then two more
years as a fellowship in neural critical
care but did you say there were years
after undergrad before med school that
was during med school I did my PhD okay
not all MDS do phds too
correct
okay that's a lot of training
Fellowship was in what specifically
neuro Critical Care
all right so neuro
critical care this is like when people
are in hit their head and they're in big
trouble that's correct or they get a
stroke they're in big trouble that's
right they call you in and you sometimes
you think you're gonna go uh
go swimming for fun and you just get
called in for like 14 hours straight
that's right to work on one patient
right
all right merry kids
yes uh
have you reviewed some materials in this
case I have
all right so the the jury just heard
from a
um
neuro radiologist
and you are a neurologist
okay
distinguish the two again really quick
so a neuroradiologist reads
images MRIs CTS x-rays all kinds of
images of the brain and the spinal cord
okay and you neurologists do what we
diagnose and treat conditions of the of
the nervous system so brain spinal cord
peripheral nerves and then this
afternoon we're going to hear from a
neuropsychologist what's that
a neuropsychologist uh diagnose and
diagnosis and treats
disorders of Consciousness and awareness
and language that are related to
neurological conditions and do the three
of you work together on hard cases yes
and do you rely for instance upon a
neural radiologist and a
neuropsychologist all the time yes
um okay
you know I was kidding when I said nerd
really I'm I'm
praising you in a backward way I
apologize if that sounded passive
aggressive we call ourselves an earth
that's okay
all right you were here for Dr Black's
testimony on the neuroradiology is that
true yes and one of his opinions was
that Dr
Mr sanderson's
brain problems that he complains of as a
result of the Collision or were actually
all pre-existing did you hear Dr Black
say that yes I did and do you agree with
that opinion yes
yes let's talk about what you've
reviewed so
I think uh
yesterday you told me you had received
some 3 000 pages of
junk
just kidding materials right correct and
a big chunk of those were medical
records and a big chunk of those were
depositions correct and then you also
received a lot of images before and
after that's correct and did you all did
you review all of that yes over several
years
do you believe you have a foundation to
render the opinions you're about to
render in this case yes I do in addition
to what you've reviewed your background
education training and experience do you
believe that all comes to bear in
rendering the opinions you're about to
give
so your honor uh
I think this will be the most efficient
he's prepared a written report that has
some headings and I would like to just
go to the and and have James bring up
just the headings
I think you can just read them
I don't think he has to show the jury I
think
I think are we talking about a
demonstrative exhibit to illustrate this
witness's testimony no no we're talking
about just the headings of his report
all right
reports are not admissible not admiss
admitting them agreed but I think it
might be efficient to do it that way
it's no different than the witness
walking up to a chalkboard and writing
the words out on a board
so I'm I'm fine with it
if you just show the headings
thank you so
uh
did you prepare a written report by the
way yes and I have it with me and it's
broken down into some headings yes and I
thought this would be helpful can you
read heading number one
the persisting neurological symptoms Mr
Sanderson reports since the February
2016 ski accident are likely
attributable to pre-existing health
conditions okay is that indeed your
opinion yes and on what is it based
so it's so based on my review of the the
records
his mental health professionals that
evaluated in before and after if you
look at the the trajectory of that those
evaluations it looks
essentially the same before and after
also based on review of The Imaging
and afterwards the neuropsychology
testing that was that was normal or
above normal
compared to population
okay let's
let's hit all of them and then we'll go
back if needed let's are you able to
bring up two
well he brings up number two comment
upon the patient's pre-existing injuries
which ones did you find particularly
important
the pre-existing condition of depression
and anxiety is the most is is the most
Salient okay existing condition and uh
how is it that his pre-existing
depression and anxiety
is related to his complaints of
post-collision symptoms
so the depression and anxiety can cause
all the symptoms that that he is
complaining of post-collision and a few
if you were to if you look at the
records and you were able to remove the
Collision just so you'd you know just
make it evaporate
the history reads coherently
this is a man in his 70s with depression
and anxiety and it's gotten bad enough
to the point that it's impairing memory
and concentration and and other
activities that he was used to doing
so it's another way of saying that if we
removed the Collision he never had a
collision that day
it still makes sense his trajectory
right if you if you read his the medical
records from before the injury through
now
and you remove the injury it doesn't
change the trajectory of his his
complaints so for evaluation by his
health professionals for instance if if
we look at his medical record let's say
just two weeks before three weeks before
do you know he went to the VA doctor
that day yeah with complaints of I'm I'm
feeling really old I can't do what I
used to be able to do
uh that was pre-injury correct correct
and then you compare it to his
his uh Records even soon after the
Collision
you're saying it doesn't really show
anything happened
correct hasn't changed his course okay
and whenever you're ready James
can you read your opinion number two
the only neurological problems Mr
Sanders
reading a report to the jury you can
tell it no problem with that but it
shouldn't be reading it we already dealt
with this yeah overruled I think I I
Ruled on it go ahead
the only neurological problems Mr
Sanderson has had maybe partly a vet
start over the only neurological
problems Mr Sanderson has had that may
be be partly attributable to the ski
accident
are those associated with the mild
concussion he experienced during the
accident okay can you fill in the the
meat on those bones help us understand
that a little
you know so my opinion is if he had a
concussion it was very mild and
um
you know more likely than not I would
say 95 percent or more that he would
have made a full recovery from that
concussion Within within a few weeks you
know
not more than 99 percent within a few
months based on the the severity of the
concussion
so I think he's saying
I'm in that like one percent I'm not in
the 95 and the 99
how do you respond to that
so I would say if you know as a as a
neurologist I have patients that that
come in they have they complain of
cognitive symptoms memory loss attention
problems
um
difficulty doing things that they used
to do and
they can be they can have depression and
anxiety they may have early signs of
dementia
um
those things are far more common
for for someone in
Mr sanderson's category man in their 70s
they don't feel the way that they they
used to feel I feel like they're getting
old like you said before the accident or
after the accident concern that they may
be getting Alzheimer's disease
so I I think those things are far more
likely
than a very minor concussion causing
symptoms seven years later do you see
hundreds of those patients a year who've
never had a ski Collision correct
okay any other comment on your opinion
number two that you would like to make
no I think that that concludes it thank
you James is going to bring up number
three
and do you have it there
I do should I just read it start reading
it there you go the neurological
problems associated with the mild
concussion Mr Sanderson may have
experienced resolve within months they
were not permanent as plaintiffs experts
claim
okay mild concussion you aren't here but
but did you hear Dr Edgley uh testifier
or read his deposition I've read the
deposition all right so did he talk
about hey a couple things we look at as
length of objection mistakes there's no
deposition
stain
okay comment I I did miss by speak I
forgot you didn't take his deposition
um
is the is there some importance in
determining the severity of concussion
uh in terms of how long their
unconscious is that a factor yeah length
of Amnesia length of loss of
consciousness or length length of
confusion all right
I think those were the same three he
said
um all right what do you know about a
length of unconsciousness
from my assessment looking through the
records I I don't think that there was
loss of consciousness
okay uh
even if there was some loss of
consciousness it would have been brief
is that fair seconds yeah
and uh
let's see in terms of I think to be fair
I think Mr Ramon said he was
uh spread eagle head down
out cold over two minutes uh
just want to put that in the record not
substantiated by any other witness but
did you at least observe that
yeah you know
it's not
a conference to assess someone's
credibility and he wasn't there that's
what I'm going to
that why don't you clarify your question
yeah
um
what do you know about that isn't that
someone saying longer period of
unconsciousness
I'm actually trying to help the
plaintiff
go ahead
the witness is asking if you remember
reading that I do okay
is the significant time to be
unconscious is that five minutes are
over
yes
all right and then comment you said
period of amnesia
what what do you understand on that is
length of Amnesia what do you understand
the period of time that the the person
that that has the injury is not able to
remember either before or after the
event
and uh
are you are you uh acknowledging that Mr
Sanderson had a mild concussion
more likely than not he did he had
headache in one of the I think it was
the InstaCare report and so that would
that would be consistent with a mild
concussion
and it resolved within months what do
you base that on
I believe there was a report where he
said it's getting better
okay and they are not permanent as
plaintiff's claim please comment correct
so
the it was the head injury was very mild
I mean it fell in the most mild category
of of concussion so kind of like grade
one
and
the rest of the symptoms that he that he
has
what could could be caused by other
conditions which I would say are more
common
and do you believe that more likely than
uh that is why he continues to have some
symptoms yes
in other words not because of the ski
Collision but just because of his aging
Progressive
brain correct
let's read your fourth opinion
there are a total of six by the way
ladder two we might just touch on
briefly
to the fourth uh opinion is that Mr
Sanderson does not currently need
ongoing neurological treatment
that's related to the ski Collision
that's related to this key Collision so
I will yeah
so I have to modify that slightly
because this report was written before
the assessment
by Dr Goldstein was available to me
right
um
Goldstein I think recommended some con
some care with regard to dementia
correct did you hear that personally
I didn't hear it personally but I read
it in his actual report that from when
he evaluated Mr Sanderson uh do you
believe Mr Sanderson to have a sort of
dementia symptoms yes
can't possibly comment on that without a
clinical evaluation it's a speaking
objection
is it in the report
do you have symptoms so he's commenting
on his further needs and he's commenting
on uh
Sam Goldstein there's nothing why don't
you ask a question then we'll see
go ahead and ask your next question
okay so you said Mr Sanderson does not
currently need
ongoing neurologic treatment true
correct that's what that's what the
report says okay
since you wrote this did did you then uh
read Sam goldstein's uh updated opinion
yes
yes is there a drug that treats dementia
yes what is that called
it's called Aricept no opinion on
dementia sustained thank you
why is it your opinion that's Mr
Sanderson does not currently need
ongoing neurologic
treatment
related to the ski injury is the
addition you make
ski injury caused a mild concussion more
likely than not that was self-limited
and his ongoing symptoms are more likely
due to ongoing
pre-existing conditions and possibly new
conditions
bring up
can
d106
no it has not
sex
the objection
oh
this is for demonstrative purposes only
that means we can
also write on it can we not
why don't we address that if if we need
to later
defendants exhibit 106 is received
and demonstrative
and do you have it in front of you
approach
I want to make sure you can see it and
James if you can bring it up that would
be good
foreign
yes and do you do you agree with it
yes I do
it's entitled Mr sanderson's a brain
Imaging both before and after ski
Collision
uh did it show atrophy loss of brain
cell signs a sign of Aging Brain before
and after
yes did his images
actually a roaming microphone but maybe
it needs to be higher up volume loss
and grain size size of the sign of Aging
brain did he have this before and after
I object to this testimony
or do you personally read them too I
look at the films then I can confirm
with their report and then I
uh
bring it together with what we see
clinically
so I think the objection is somehow that
you're not competent to talk about the
Imaging before versus after do you agree
or disagree I disagree
and how so
so I've looked at the images uh they um
these are pretty standard MRI images
that we that we see every day and a
major part of my practice as an
outpatient neurologist was evaluating
patients for dementia and specifically
and NPH so hundreds of patients with the
question of whether they had mph which
is that hydrocephalus it's the
hydrocephalus at the bottom all right so
is it true that neuroradiologists
essentially serve you
they don't personally talk to patients
you order it the neural radiologist to
do a study then it comes back to you and
you are the one who's face to face with
the patient correctly I I translate this
just a second sir I'm sorry
um sustained Esther as to Leading okay
uh may I have I established sufficient
foundations which does have the
scientific technical or other
specialized knowledge that will help the
jury so you may proceed okay we talked
about atrophy and volume loss in large
ventricles
a ventricle is what in the brain is that
like at Halloween when we see it a mold
of a brain it's the
it's the little gooey stuff going out
you tell me no
it's the inside the brain there's
fluid-filled sacs that contain spinal
fluid
so it's the black thing in the middle on
the the MRI that Dr Black went through
all right and is that like the main
blood feeding the brain what are they
now the what purpose do The ventricle
serves they they buoy the brain so when
the so it prevents the brain from having
as much shock when when we just move
around in everyday life all right
chronic microvascular disease is that
something he had before and after yes
that was described by Dr Black
is that associated with cognitive
decline
it can be and why does he have that is
that from this stroke event uh years
earlier or just bad luck or eating too
many donuts or what I think it's a
combination of his high blood pressure
and high cholesterol with a you know a
little bit of genetics that makes our
blood vessels harder than average white
matter disease we've talked about that a
little bit it says they're damage to
nerve fibers associated with memory
balance and mobility issues did he have
that before and after yes
and is that Progressive in nature
it didn't look that
like unbelievably Progressive looks
stable over time why does the why did he
have that was that associated with the
stroke event
you know I think it's it's probably
associated with the chronic
microvascular disease the stroke event
was in in his eye
no evidence of trauma before or after is
that true that's correct
concern for disease due to excess fluid
buildup that's the NPH was that a
concern before and a concern after yes
does he in fact have that condition
so that that would be a condition that I
would need further clinical evaluation
to determine but that his MRI would be
consistent with that condition
you mentioned earlier that uh
his his conditions are not permanent as
plaintiff's experts claim
and I just want to comment uh
do you believe Dr Fong to have used
unreliable signs to make some of her
opinions objection bleeding
irrelevant
so if I sustain an injection just hold
off sorry thanks
they're about to get up and criticize
you for not seeing this patient why uh
why didn't you why wouldn't you what why
would it be necessary if you needed to
yep so why I would always be willing
um and
actually didn't know that was an option
but
in this case
um and with many patients in in my
practice
we review tons of Records before we see
them actually Mr Sanderson probably had
10 times the amount of records that I
have before I see my patients in clinic
you said three thousand pages and lots
of Imaging
so I can know
with 90 certainty going in based on the
the before and after Imaging the
neuropsych testing over a period of
years the
um
his reports over time I can know with 90
accuracy with what's going on so if I if
I went in there I'd be trying to figure
out does he have NPH or not and what can
I do to help him with his depression
anxiety and other memory problems would
you be treating them or evaluating the
ski injury
no I would I'd be providing counseling
that the ski injury was not part of it
now you you refer people all the time to
neuropsychologists is that true yes and
we're about to hear from two
um but you did have the benefit of
multiple neuropsychologist exams at the
VA is that true correct and uh do you
know them to be good neuropsychologists
I don't I don't know them okay uh do you
know them to be not hired by either side
his normal treating providers yes that's
my understanding and uh these were
voluminous evaluations were they not yes
and
um
and what
what did they conclude
they were essentially normal they showed
that he was performing above average
now is that above average for everyone
on the street or for a 75 year old man
with college educations or what for 75
year old man with college educations and
okay so with a high Baseline
so
um
in some places even like near Superior
correct levels yes so
um
I'm gonna grab one thing
I think the jury's seen various uh
neuropsych overviews
but do you agree it was tested and uh
tens and tens and tens of categories yes
did you see any of them below average no
did you see many above average yes
IQ for instance was 114 is that right
that's my recollection and for like a 75
year old man with the college education
uh is that good yeah it's above average
okay what's average again 100 okay
now I think they're going to say hey
there are the family members are
saying
we're noticing he's angrier angrier than
he used to be or that he's he can't uh
drive and read at the same time
but there's things he can't multitask
with can you comment on that
so you know in people
like Mr Sanderson who are high
functioning at Baseline you know above
average IQ you know Superior in some
categories like like you described
you know
a drop in functioning might still look
like he's really high functioning
compared to the average population
in the family
will will pick up on some of these
changes right they they see what they
see
um
and um
yeah that concludes that okay
so if you did meet with Mr Sanderson and
he kept uh obsessively bringing up I
think the ski Collision caused this what
would you say
I would
I would I would
say that it's my job as a neurologist to
help him accept that that's not part of
what he's experiencing now
more likely way more likely than not
he has a history of depression anxiety
we know he continues to be anxious so
that needs treatment
and I would you know evaluate
for dementia like we said as
would be indicated by his Imaging okay
and so my job is to help
the patient and family gain acceptance
that this mild event seven years ago
isn't causing all these problems that
he's having now or any of them right
right didn't you tell me the the cure
for Mr Sanderson is the end of this
lawsuit
correction
no Foundation relevance improper
questioning
overruled go ahead
is that your opinion yeah I mean I felt
anxious coming here I also objected that
started his report
nowhere to be found
overruled go ahead just explain that and
then I'm sitting down I mean the the
you know suing somebody going through a
trial a trial that has you know National
recognition can bring on a lot of
anxiety and if you're prone to that
it's gonna it's gonna make it worse and
it's gonna
slow your recovery his daughter said
this notoriety makes him feel
powerful did you read that in Jenny's
deposition
Chinese depth position is not in in
evidence sustained
coming into evidence Council if we have
time we're going to read it in we'll
it's been referenced multiple times
if if you're planning to ask this
witness about evidence that's not part
of the case
or it won't be part of the case then
it's an improper question okay if he's
read it as part of his opinions
experts can rely upon hearsay they can
yeah but it's not referencing his report
well if it's not in his report then
sustained okay I'll let you go thank you
Mr Sykes
Steve
come on
doctor do you commonly
uh
render opinions on your patients without
a clinical exam no no
and the last
100 patients that you've seen
or that are referred to you
how many have you
rendered opinions on for other doctors
without an examination a clinical exam
so I mean we do have conversations with
our doctors where they say hey you know
what do you think about this case and I
may render an opinion without seeing the
patient but if it's my own patient then
then it's part of my standard evaluation
to see them
if it's your own patient
your last thousand patients that were
your own patients you would never
render opinions about them without a
clinical exam is that a fair statement
No never I would form an opinion but I
wouldn't
create a treatment plan and execute on
it without seeing them so a clinical
exam would you agree
for this jury
is an important factor for a physician
correct yeah
uh did you read the opinion of Dr
actually testified yesterday
the um no I did not
uh if he called the clinical
exam the gold standard for a physician
would you agree or disagree with that
overruled as to relevance the jury will
recall the testimony of Dr Edgley well
in all honesty he didn't say it in his
testimony said in his report I'm asking
if he said in this report would that
make a difference
there are no facts and evidence I would
draw the question thank you but would
you agree excuse me
is that a clinic that a clinical
examination is the gold standard
for a physician who's treating somebody
not sure what a gold standard means
pretty important it's a big part of my
evaluation excuse me
um
secondly I'd look through your opinion
pretty carefully was about four or five
pages
I noted
let me see if I can get it here handy
yeah
well I'll just ask you if you remember
this
that's on my computer
but you had a list of uh
things that you reviewed is that right
yes okay
can you tell this jury
a summary of what Carlene Davidson said
in her deposition
about Terry before and after the ski
crash
I can't from memory
okay
can you tell the jury
what Holly Gresham
the daughter
said about Terry
before and after the ski crash
yes I did I did read Miss grashem's
deposition this weekend or her statement
but you didn't read Carly Davidson I
think I did but I can't remember all the
names if you want to show it to me I can
comment on it tell the jury
you can
what important information about Terry
before and after the ski crash polygrash
in a second
feels that he you know is not as engaged
and able to do things in the way that he
used to that's probably the summary
that's a pretty mild statement of it
isn't it
excuse me
that there was a marked
and sudden
difference in her father in a wide
variety
of areas
personality executive functioning
social problems after the ski crash
almost immediately didn't she say that
I'm not sure she said executive
functioning but the rest of it sounds
familiar
position
remind me of the relationship daughter
no I did not okay
those three are listed and you did you
read or not read Carlene Davidson
I read it but I I can't remember what it
says you read it but you can't remember
it
tell the jury of Shea Harris is listed
there as one you had
s-h-a-e
I don't see it
foreign
let me show you what you wrote
can
can we move to admit our report
s
I guess I I don't you may be opening the
door to the report
okay
take a look at it
EMS uh
four l m and n
correct
I don't see Shea Harris like you said I
think that was the question
there I do see Carlene and Polly
so
the defense did not give you
Shay Harris right
correct
hypothetically if Shea said there was a
a very very Sudden Change in my dad
before and after for neuropsycholog what
we call neuropsychological symptoms
would that make a difference in your
opinion
it might have made a difference at the
time okay but at this point in time it
would not
uh
Carlene Davidson testified she was a
second witness in the trial last week
are you does this ring a bell that she
was
living with Terry for about a year and a
half before the ski accident does
everything about that does
and she was up here about 300 days a
year
in Salt Lake from Saint George right
that was yeah and they also spent time
in St George together yep
and they went on International trips
together
is that right yes uh do you think she
would get to know him pretty well during
their time yes
defined
that there was a
rampant and severe change in Terry after
the ski crash
that lasted and she stayed with her for
six months and then they parted ways
she said she was heartbroken
she was hoping for a marriage out of
this
is a compound
stand okay she was hoping for a marriage
out of this
do you remember that in her deposition
yes yeah
but he changed fundamentally after the
ski crash now does that does that make a
difference in your opinions at all
I mean it would be part of
the whole companion of what I would put
together yes I didn't read anything
about that
I read your reports about four pages
aside from their depositions that you
referenced you don't say anything at all
in your report
about the rapid and fundamental changes
that occurred to Terry after the ski
crash
don't even mention them
is that correct
that's correct
now
are you familiar with the term executive
functioning yes
is that something that
neurologists use term that neurologists
use sometimes yes
because you realize of course as a
neurologist
that you can have
massive changes in a person with a mild
TBI that don't show up on Imaging right
that's yes that's possible Yeah you
mentioned that earlier in your in your
testimony yeah
um
and a category of those changes
is called executive functioning right
that is one manifestation potentially
yes
it's one category yeah
uh and I didn't see the word executive
functioning even addressed in your
report not even a mention correct
sorry is that a question or yeah correct
the question with a inflection for a
question yes
is it in my report yeah no it's not in
the report okay hey Pete would you uh
now while he's doing that
could you define what a jury executive
functioning
medical sense the ability to to do
things to start actions and carry
through with them
to start actions into what carry through
carry the actions through yeah
that's uh self-regulated self-directed
action right correct okay
uh and that people use that to manage
their Affairs effectively
correct right yep
have you heard of Sam Goldston
all right I I mean I know of his report
as I testified earlier and I've read
some of his deposition
I actually saw his testimony
and by the way were you aware that he is
a
world renowned neuropsychologist from
Salt Lake City yes yeah
and he developed an executive function
test
correct can you see it on the on your
screen there I do yeah and here's
what he recorded
with a
high confidence level
that this man Terry Sanderson
who is a former captain in the United
States Army
ran eye clinics for the Army
has an advanced degree in Optometry
which I think it's a four-year degree if
I'm not mistaken
and ran two clinics in Southern Idaho
okay
would that indicate to you a man of
superior
intelligence and executive function yes
yeah let's see what he did here
okay
on attention
he was in the 25th percentile
does that strike you as strange or just
average by the way
25th percentile in other words out of a
hundred people he's 25 lowest right
that's correct that's what that means
that that for a man of his attainment
he's only the 25th percentile on
attention
world-renowned neuropsychologist
recorded this
strike you as odd
strikes me as him having issues like we
talked about
condition I'm sorry I'll skip emotional
just I was saying I you know I think you
know these are data and they're good
data and it reinforces my stance that Mr
Sanderson needs help he's got depression
and anxiety and I think this could be
consistent with dementia as well okay by
the way
uh let me show you where it is
we got the court motivation yes
no is that that's
yes
it's just an exhibit notebook here my
Approach
[Music]
do you have the number of that yeah it
was uh 43.
sir can I just ask what date this is
okay so was this 2012 Foundation to the
witness your honor
okay
I lay before you
the French exhibits
and plaintiff's exhibits
can you show us where there's a
diagnosis of dementia
this is
going back to 2009
and up through I think 2021. what hasn't
been made yet
it has been made okay
so because we're you would agree for the
juries
help here
uh despite the fact that we're in a
very important worldwide case okay like
you mentioned
paraphrasing your words there's no
diagnosis of dementia
it hasn't hasn't been made yet yeah
because we're
we're talking about a minor brain injury
that happened in 2016 and not allowing
him to move on to have a true diagnosis
let's talk about flexibility
exhibit 43.
low average 23rd percentile for
flexibility
of a man who ran two clinics in Southern
Idaho
does that sound really low
sounds low yeah by the way you asked me
the date I think this was done in 2020.
okay
uh
it's just a couple organization
now the ability to organize things is a
very important part of executive
function isn't it correct very important
part
third percentile
now I'm just a simple country lawyer
if that were me I'd understand it
but I didn't run two clinics
okay yeah
third percentile does that strike you is
indicative of something wrong here
yeah
planning and by the way below average
low average she was planning
fourth percentile
below average does that strike you is
very low for a man of his attainment
very low
self-monitoring 10 percent
that strike you is very low for a man of
his attainment
it does what about working memory for a
man who did everything he did
working memory of five percentile
it's love all right now
um how do I make one more comment on
that by the way well you want to move on
oh let's just move on it's related to
goldstein's report what's that you know
my my impression from goldstein's report
is that that's why he was recommending
the colonace and a colon esterase
inhibitor based on these kinds of
findings well
uh which is a treatment for dementia if
uh you don't remember specific things
about his executive functioning from his
family do you
no I don't yeah
um or from Carlene
but they Carlene told this jury just a
week ago
but there was a major change in these
things
overnight
and she couldn't live with it
all right now
um
come off here
I don't get it cold very often but this
is a killer
um
did you see anywhere in these records
okay now let me just preface this
Terry Sanderson
has been a patient
of
Veterans Administration he was a veteran
yeah
I think for since the early part of
the century early 2000s
when he moved down here from Idaho right
and uh he's got a lot of Records there
and there are a lot of records that you
read
after February 16 26 of 2016. correct
yeah now in those records
do you see anywhere
anywhere
where Terry Sanderson
was accused of Faking malingering or
magnifying symptoms for money
no sir nothing there a job okay
nobody says I meant it for the money
yeah and you have did you read the
reports of Goldstein or Goldstein Fong
and Gibby
I did they're all treating positions for
him correct you where they're treating
yes okay they're all pretty confident
aren't they yes Dr Fong said she's
treated thousands thousands of patients
with mild TBI you wear that
he wasn't aware of the number but I know
that she treats she missed trial here
because she's lecturing over in Holland
on on what she does she's lecturing in
the Netherlands
you aware of that no I'm not I think she
was going to Spain after that anyway uh
and and she said
and by the way are you aware that these
kind of doctors at least this
neuropsychologist they give tasks that
have embedded
cleverly embedded tasks for malindri you
wear that I am yeah and and neither the
VA or
these three doctors found any suggestion
any suggestion
of Faking or malingering or
magnification
or you wear that correct or any
suggestion that he's doing this for
money
right it's an insulting comment but
there's no suggestion of that is there I
didn't see any other do you think he's
doing it for money
I don't know I have no opinion on that
thank you
um now
with respect to
um
the you know
thing up there about his um
uh his scans CT and MRI remember that
chart correct and and you saw uh Dr
Black yes I did his testimony a few
minutes ago yes I did okay
and uh
uh you remember him saying
that from 2009 through 2021
there's no indication of a change on
these schemes correct yeah so there's no
deterioration that's the that's the big
point
he hasn't deteriorated on the scans
has he
correct that was Dr Black's testimony
and you agree that he had a mild
concussion
correct more likely than not well likely
not okay that's good enough and you also
agree that he's not uh
uh and I think in your report
you said Mr Owen said one percent but
you said five percent
of people with this condition
mild traumatic brain injury do not
recover completely
correct okay now
do you think
that an executive functioning
outcome like that
is more toward
the five percent
what do you think
I don't you don't no okay
uh is is the fact that
uh the people that love him that know
him the best
say there was a significant and sudden
dramatic change in him after this ski
crash
do you think that moves in more toward
the five percent
I don't you don't
you think the fact that no one has
diagnosed him with any other condition
like dementia moves in more toward the
fine percent no you think that no the
fact that no one's diagnosed him
with faking malingering magnification
moves in more toward the fine percent no
okay
we talked about
atrophy in the Aging brain
okay
that is a normal condition right it can
be and it's asymptomatic in many people
it can be okay
yeah one more question
I'll talk to my compatriots back here
um are you familiar
with the pre-existing exacerbation
issue medically with brain injury in
other words let me explain that
if you have a pre-existing let's say you
have a problem with anger regulation
or some other negative
quality okay
then oftentimes a TBI
even a mild TBI can exacerbate those
symptoms you aware of that I am and
that's a that's a true principle of
medicine isn't it correct okay one
second
would you agree that um
a person
who's had a concussion
is a greater risk
if they have another concussion second
injury syndrome they call it yes okay
that's all I've got Josh thank you
thank you thank you Mr Owens
and James are you hooked up thanks
uh in our last witness with Dr Black we
actually referred to a document
a plane of 33 page eight and nine
that was admitted
and we're gonna uh and maybe just bring
up
just number two if you would
I don't know if you're are you able just
to clear number two
do you remember uh this is not part of
Dr Fong's document
yes and did you recall plaintiff's
council to say show me show me in those
records where it says the word dementia
yes all right so let's look at this the
most likely diagnosis for this
appearance is normal pressure
hydrocephalus
the differential would include normal
aging brain
Alzheimer's dementia
subcortical arterial sclerosclerotic
encephalopathy and
multi-in-fart dementia
all right this is plaintiff's own
retained expert right yeah
and she's talking about hey
could be some dementia stuff going on
here right correct objection that's a
differential diagnosis and it doesn't
suggest that's a speaking objection
there are it's inappropriate so it's
inappropriate
overruled overruled you can
cross-examine you can cross-examine the
witnesses and then Peter if you can hear
my voice come back in I had him go make
some copies of another dementia
reference that will will pull up in just
a minute
do you remember any reference in the VA
where the patient actually came to the
doctor and said I'm worried that I am
getting dementia yes and what do you
recall I think that might have been his
treating psychiatrist Michael McIntosh
uh does this sound familiar I think
that's right
do you recall uh Peter making copies but
do you recall what he responded
I don't okay we'll pull that up in just
a minute
in terms of how close these daughters
were in their impersonal observations
Did You observe that Paulie grasm
Sanders
had not even seen or talked to her dad
for three months prior to this ski
Collision yeah
sustain
they all lived out of state is that fair
all three daughters lived out of state
from him
it's overruled
yes
and he had in fact at the time of the
ski Collision he wasn't running a two
office Optometry a visit he'd been
retired many years correct correct and
there's been evidence that he left on
bad terms with his Partners there's no
evidence for that in this
overruled and it's irrelevant
did you recall this I'm sorry I don't
recall that part that he left on poor
terms he left his community on poor
terms his business
I'll clarify my question
so I don't want just continuing speaking
objections for sure
right now well we talk about this
okay I you know I understand your issue
that you you think it's collateral
impeachment and that uh it's beyond the
scope of cross I'm going to overrule the
objections uh but ask that there not be
a lot of repetition
I think that the door was opened when he
was this witness was asked about the
before and the after from family
I'm trying to recall my last question
too that was the objection was sustained
or it was rejected
and then but there was continuing talk
and I never even got to ask it well
you'll have a few minutes to re-equate
reorient yourself
Dr Hess you can certainly step down
during the break oh thank you
leaving this Hometown that he never let
that in
and it's a collateral issue which I
might have to go into pursue in the time
of election makes no difference
indications years before
I thought there was testimony
of both parties well I thought there was
testimony of of issues with his when he
left his business that there were issues
so I mean we can't bring up with all
froze
no I'm asking I'm asking you to to
explain where well first of all where
did that come in sure
it's in Terry's deposition by the way I
think he even used the word like his
partner had
uh
deposition then it's not in the record
only because I have been able to finish
with Terry but his own daughter for
instance said that he left he enjoyed a
good reputation until his affair in that
community that was in the record that's
in our that's is that on the record
that's in evidence
no
no it's in evidence because you were
making him out to be just this
beautifully respected man in the
community and his own daughter said not
so you said well well I think
business partner problem
S
I know I've read it I just don't know if
it came out on the record I don't think
it did so I know it to be true because
Mr uh Sanderson so actually
uh so I asked him
we're not proving truth necessarily
right now we're proving did you see it
in that record because they can testify
as to what they've reviewed and then
then I can follow up on it so it doesn't
have to be in as a fact as a fact I
think under 403 I'll exclude it that
question which one again you're on about
business dispute business okay
and you know like a certain amount of
cross-examination with this witness you
know and the closer it is to what the
daughters observed or didn't observe uh
the closer it's Tethered to that the
more relevant it is to the to the to
responding to the cross that came out
but if you're you know to pull out I
guess the defense's laundry list of
complaints about the plaintiff or not
complaints but points
um I don't know that this is the correct
this is the most appropriate place to do
that given the scope of direct all the
family members are saying he had
dramatic changes before and I've been
saying actually they're pretty distant
and sure so up so questions that are
Tethered to those issues are fine okay
and just so we know what we're doing as
soon as we go on we're going to rep uh
present
um VA records 922 to 9 24 and then what
so that's defense exhibits what
are you introducing these are you just
showing them
I'm about to find out
here
and just just for the future
um I'd like to reiterate that when you
have an objection all I need is
objection and the rule what rule and if
if I need more information I'll ask for
it
sure
we usually take about 10 minutes for
these breaks
thank you
company any rulings of the Court any
arguments of the lawyers anything
that's going on I would hate to have to
ask you know someone to leave so if you
could please keep your thoughts to
yourself keep your reactions your
emotions even your facial expressions
until you until Court's not in session
so thank you
we're ready
Mr Owens you may may continue
the court hearing at noon
your honor uh I'm circulating defense to
save at 114 may I approach you you may
do you mind if I hand it to the witness
you know
okay d114
did you say d as in dog D is in
defendant yes okay and does the
plaintiff have any objection of this
witness or this exhibit exhibit uh
defendants exhibit 114 D is received
the witness without displaying it
hey thank you very much
okay
we're good
have you seen this document
I can't can't remember this is part of
his VA records uh it's it's dated May 22
2017.
uh
bottom right is marked ba922
so if the incident was in February 2016
this is about a year
and three months later you with me yes
and if we go to page the second page
va923
and uh
James is going to bring this up
you see under the subjective uh and
James I think the address is there so
you want to get rid of it
that's where I'm going to start reading
patient reportedly yes
okay that's the first paragraph and let
me where's our cool laser
start this is a big sentence
but I'm going to start right here
patient reportedly
and I'll read this patient reportedly
sought out neuropsychological testing
for these symptoms
and also but also feared he may be
experiencing early dementia systems
symptoms
Mr Sanderson noted that he felt
reassured following the testing but is
still concerned regarding some of the
cognitive changes he has experienced so
that's another reference to him being
concerned
with dementia true true
that's all on that
you can take that down James
executive function testing does that
rely on the patient
uh some some
subjective reports from the patient
I believe so but I'll have to defer to
our neuropsychology experts later today
okay they're going to come up here and
talk about that so we'll be okay with
that
patients can throw neuro testing though
can't they can they like
fill in the tic-tac-toe
and the patient can actually say
I don't know
overruled
yes I mean we can't force him to to put
a zero where it belongs in the next
where it belongs Fair correct
and are you aware of studies that say
being a litigant in a case like this
actually
frequently leads to
um patients
overstating their damages
401 403 and Beyond
the scope overruled go ahead
yes
just comment on what you know on that
so I I would say it's more just knowing
from
medical school and learning about you
know what malingering is as opposed to
studies that you that you stayed
okay
malingering is a a word that means
basically not trying as hard
is that fair correct for secondary gain
if I'm malinger
if I have a
stubborn cough that's malingering
is that the right reuse of that word no
it would be if you were elaborating
your symptoms like you said not filling
in The Tick-Tock toe
in order to have some type of secondary
game
all right
what we do know is that he ran a
business in Idaho many years earlier
true it's true
overruled
true and then he retired he retired
in part due to his failing eyesight do
you know that I don't know that all
right
and do you know anything about uh losing
the respect of his community
which his daughter reported to this jury
projection leading
overruled
sounds familiar but I don't know the
details on that due to an affair he had
he thought
40 401 403 sustained thank you
I think it's in evidence and I think he
should be able to reference it
but I'll respect your
your ruling
can anxiety and depression and Hyper
fixation can they throw off executive
functioning yes all right
um
one thing Sam Goldstein said the other
day was that he's he's obsessed he's
obsessed with this case this notoriety
this media
uh can that throw off one's if someone's
obsessed can that throw off their
executive functioning yes objection from
foundation overruled and just comment on
that for me please
yeah so being obsessed being extremely
anxious or having other you know being
depressed kind of it's a that's a whole
continuum
can cause a whole host of cognitive
dysfunction including executive function
but also problems with concentration
attention memory
All the Above
I'm being told to sit down I'm sitting
down thank you
for Sykes
doctor in that uh report that you have
there
um the progress note from the VA
May 22 2017.
we're just looking at it exhibit 114.
okay yes sir
um
this was a
the reason we're either to destroy the
reason for the visit
would you like me to read it oh
scheduled Psychotherapy intake
and then on page two some of the things
that weren't read
here
so
it says subjective now Mr Owens
read you part of that
okay
can you see what I'm referring to here
yes okay he says uh recently referred by
Dr Manson following neuroscient testing
where anxiety was suspected to be
affecting patients cognitive functioning
you see that yes yeah and Mr Sanderson
reported that he was in a ski accident
1.5 years ago
where he was hit by another sphere who
lost control
he reportedly had a five-minute Loc
uh and and broke four ribs see that yes
and he was evaluated and told he had a
concussion
yes and that's actually what happened he
was evaluated and told he had a
concussion wasn't he
yeah uh he said over the past year and a
half
his cognition has gradually improved
right
correct now people that are malingering
don't go to other doctors that they've
improved do they do they
I don't know that I can make that
general statement but I think the fact
that he improved we talked about which
is a sign of but his continued to have
difficulties
interrupted my client I'm sorry I'm
sorry my expert that's right I'm sorry I
didn't mean to interrupt you did you
finish your response yeah I was just
saying that we we did talk about this
earlier that he had gotten better from
the concussion not gotten completely
better but he improved right
he improved that's his cognition has
gradually improved
but it's continued to have difficulties
with motivation
energy and on hedonia
that's a
term that the jury may not understand
loss of enjoyment of Life correct okay
so uh at least two of the three of those
are things you commonly see with
executive functioning problems aren't
they
motivation
energy
correct okay
he also described difficulties with
spatial tasks such as driving getting
lost
and puzzles
those are frequently executive
functioning problems aren't they yeah
they're also major signs of dementia
okay he reportedly sought out
neurosychological testing for these
symptoms
but also fear that he may be
experiencing early dementia symptoms
okay it was smart for him to think that
smart Mr Sanderson noted that he felt
reassured
from the testing but is still concerned
regarding some of the cognitive changes
he has experienced right correct and you
understand that he was tested and told
he doesn't have dementia you understand
that yes and no diagnosis
dementia ever
right
correct okay
now
also
a patient
sometimes neuropsychologists call them
clients but you call them patients right
correct
patient or client
who has high scores
in some areas
it's not generally a person who's trying
to fake it right
correct high scores right correct and in
some areas some intellectual areas Terry
Sanderson has super high scores on
testing super high
right
that's right yeah
hold on one second your honor I think
I'm done here
no funny questions
Mr Owens no your honor no more questions
thank you all right thank you Dr hasher
excused thank you for coming thank you
just leave it right there in front
thanks
you mind if I just take one more minute
I think he's excused sorry Mr Sykes
do you have another minute
very short all right come on in
you're still under oath
yes
normal pressure hydrocephaly or
hydrocephalus that's correct okay
that is a condition is it not that can
exist for years and years and years
without any symptoms
correct and the three main symptoms
of NPH if it's active
okay
are Ataxia dementia
and loss of continence
correct okay and Ataxia being problems
walking problem and there's no diagnosis
anywhere in those records before you
that anybody ever diagnosed with mph
that's right okay
a lot of good doctors looked at him
right
correct thank you
Mr Owens
and entirely separate from the ski
accident do you believe Mr Sanderson
would benefit from
anti-dementia medications I've checked
that's beyond the scope yeah it's only
about mph
that was the your honor he overruled go
ahead I think it's worth a trial low
side effects and it could could help him
and Sam Goldstein felt the same way
correct that's all thank you
thank you
Mr Sykes anything further okay thank you
Mr Owens you may call your next Witness
thank you
James has this one I'm getting the clerk
the official 114.
your honor we call Dr Angela eastboulder
a neuropsychology expert thank you
do you swear that the testimony you are
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth to help you
God
thank you
good morning
would you take a seat and then state
your name and spell it
my name is Angela eastvold
a-n-g-e-l-a-e-a-s-t-v-o-l-d
thanks for being here Dr eastvold and I
believe your honor you said we have
until you have a hearing at noon and so
we'll be quick for the first part here
would you like to end right at noon or a
little bit before maybe a couple minutes
before would be great okay great one or
two sure I'll keep my eye on the clock
Dr eastvolt um what do you understand
your role to be in this case
it's improvised
okay and were you asked to look at Dr
Goldstein plaintiff's neuropsychology
expert in his evaluation in particular
yes but you looked at every everything
you looked at all the records I did and
we don't have to name them all there are
thousands correct yes and they're they
span what period do you recall 2004 to
2022. okay
and
and I think
after we come back from the break we'll
do what we did with Dr Hesh you have a
report that also has some headings and
that will help us take it through take
help us take you through those but if we
may start with just uh a general
understanding of your expertise and why
the jury should listen to you about
these matters
so I'm a board-certified
neuropsychologist I have a PhD in
Clinical Psychology with a
specialization in neuropsychology I then
completed a two-year fellowship at the
Veterans Hospital in Tampa Florida where
I received two years of specialized
training in the full spectrum of brain
injury from mild to severe and brain
injury has been my primary area of
expertise since I was then a faculty in
the neurology department at the
University of Utah for six years and
during that time I regularly lectured to
Physicians and psychologists and
trainees on concussions and provided
continuing education courses on
concussion diagnosis and management of
this
and then I since 2011 I've also been an
independent consultant to professional
sports teams as part of their concussion
protocol that is all required now so
when a player gets a concussion they are
required to have an evaluation By Me In
order to be cleared to return to play so
I am
deeply involved in in concussion and for
the past two years my work is primarily
is 80 concussion
so in your review of Mr sanderson's
medical history and and other records I
guess we should mention did you review
the Deer Valley records I did okay the
incident report and the instructor
comments these were these uh accident
records you reviewed those yes and you
reviewed depositions connected to the
events of the Collision I did
um
so in your review of all that in Europe
what is your opinion about Mr Sanderson
as it relates to concussion
me to go into my first opinion yeah
we'll we'll get to it but just for the
general review in general that if you
suffered a concussion it was at most a
mild concussion
great and uh what about the symptoms
connected to that concussion if you had
one
that the symptoms
[Music]
resolved or the symptoms that were there
might be better explained by other
conditions
that pre-existed the Collision yes
um
okay so that's a good just general
overview anything else you would add as
a general overview of your opinions
no that's that's a good just short again
we'll get an introduction yes there's a
lot of details I'm looking forward to
going into okay great so uh I want to
pull up the
exhibit that the jury was just looking
at with Dr hash it's a plaintiff's
exhibit p43
I just switched my
iPad here into the system it looks like
it's taken a second
this is the
executive functioning table do you
recall seeing that I do and do you
recall reviewing that in
um
uh Dr goldstein's evaluation of Mr
Sanderson I do that's where this comes
from correct and
I'm gonna just pull it up right here and
ask you
what does uh this table what is it
trying to accomplish okay this is
important
um so this is a self-report measure that
Dr Goldstein himself designed and
published
um I can't speak to it it's not
something that is commonly administered
in clinical practice for adults I've
never seen it used anywhere other than
Dr Goldstein so I can't speak to about
the validity of these scales but what I
can say is that this is a really nice
quantification of the patient's
subjective complaints it is not evidence
of objective deficits it's just a
summary and quantification of what the
patient is reporting
and so if you if you would for the jury
when when you use those terms subjective
and objective in a neuropsychological
sense what do you mean by them so
subjective is just patient's opinion or
perception objective is something that
is measurable and when we get into the
neuropsychological test results those
numbers are objective data and I will
later show you how some of these
contradict some of the objective data
so is it your opinion that the results
here that plaintiff's attorneys have
been going through those represent only
Mr sanderson's report of his his own
sense of his executive functioning
exactly
um and there's other evaluating
um Physicians or neuropsychologists that
have done objective evaluations is that
correct correct and you can you give us
this just brief sense of what those are
when they happened so he had
um a a battery of tests that measure
multiple areas of attention one month
post injury he had a battery of tests
that measures
um multiple aspects of memory two months
post injury and then he had a full
neuropsychological evaluation one year
post injury and what did those and then
we had Dr goldstein's evaluation which
is four years post injury right thank
you so in all those evaluations uh what
would you say as a summary of the
findings
there's nothing in her report about this
it is in my report and I would love to
be able to talk about it in the context
of my first of my so yeah they'll have
to deal with the objection that's okay
that's quite all right I will do that
maybe we could do that over lunch sure
um and do you have another area that you
want to go into for the next five
minutes it seems like there's a good
time to wrap up if okay why don't we
take our recess now and then we'll
return it
1 25. okay thank you thank you
not a deposition is that right okay let
me pull that up and then I can address
your objection
and if we can your honor and we know
we're on the clock and this is we're in
the sort of the last
um
five hours or so of evidence if we can
get an update we would like one okay
yeah we can do that over the noon hour
all right so uh remind me again what was
your question Mr Egan
just asking about the post-accident
evaluations and she does discuss those I
believe under section three of her
report
also in section one cognitive
Assessments in March and April of 2016.
she talks about those there and then she
talks about gold scenes in the 2017 Dr
evaluation
degree okay and so that's that was the
direction that you were going based on
using the parameters of her reporting
yeah
yeah it also talks about is March and
April 2016. March 8th of 2016. and this
is under three neuropsycho evaluation
completed in 2017 and then she touched
evaluation in 2020
so the subject matter in general is
certainly within the scope of her report
so objections overruled
those paragraphs in you'll see him
excuse me
all right so objections overruled on
that question and uh if you need the
court I mean I this pre-trial should
take no more than 45 minutes so you can
let the clerk know and we could get back
together if necessary but otherwise 125.
no I'll go to the next courtroom
and then I intend to ask Terry Sanderson
to the stand can we confirm your honor
yeah in the courtroom this afternoon
your honor uh they've released Terry
Sanderson they said they weren't going
to call him again
yeah yesterday
so that was that was for the uh to to
complete their Cross of the scope of
your direct they're going to call them
under the rules as the adverse witnessed
in their own case so
anything else Council no I just want to
make sure he's in the courtroom this
afternoon
in the courtroom or available to
testifying
can you make them available Mr Sykes
this afternoon no problem right okay
thank you
the plaintiff has used 42 minutes and
the defendant has used one hour and 35
minutes
42 minutes for the plaintiff one hour
and 35 minutes for the defendant
if I have time
foreign
wow
thank you may be seated
Council are we ready for the jury
Council
tuition I can tell you what I understand
um
let me pull it up
my understanding
his defendant has four more hours
including
closing arguments tomorrow
thank you for doing this oh sure
excuse me sure
well between this afternoon and tomorrow
there's approximately five and a half
hours of jury time available
in the time that I have that each party
has taken
is 16 for the plane of 16 hours in one
minute
and for the defendant 16 hours and 25
minutes does that compart with your
computation
1601 and 1625.
so
can you calculate what I have left that
will help me
well if there's five hours and 30
minutes left
you get less than half of that
right
if we take one hour apart one hour for
each party to occur tomorrow for
closings
then can we calculate what's
uh we want to comply with the Court's
order on this
both sides want an hour tomorrow for
closing is that true vlog
I might want more than that okay at
least one hour
so that lead that's about six hours and
30 minutes in front of the jury
including closing arguments
so the uh which is roughly divided
to where the defendant would have three
hours and three minutes and the
plaintiff would have three hours and 27
minutes
and then if we take out
the one hour closing tomorrow one hour
each that leads us about two hours each
today two 203 for the defendants two of
227 for the plaintiff
and and I'm not saying that has to
happen I mean that can't happen today
because
we don't have enough time to do it today
because that's five that's almost five
and a half that is five and a half hours
right there
okay ready for the jury then
okay
once you come on and take the witness
stand be ready
foreign
you may continue
we're back from lunch and yes
I think it'd be best to just go right
into your opinions
your honor to have permission to do as
we did with Dr hash show The Heading of
the report
yes thank you so I'll put that up here
on the screen here Dr eastvold is this
the first opinion in your report yes and
maybe let's just read it plaintiff
suffered at most a mild concussion from
the Collision occurring on 2 26 2016.
okay so and why is that your opinion
okay so when I'm forming an opinion on
whether there's been a concussion or not
there's three main things that I'm
looking at one the mechanism of injury
is it sufficient enough to cause a a
concussion to the acute injury
characteristics what symptoms were
present in the minutes and hours
immediately after the collision and then
what did the clinical course look like
after that and I'm most interested in
the three to four months after an injury
things that are happening after that are
less likely associated with the
concussion okay so those are the three
things I'm looking at so one the
mechanism so there was a collision two
people ran into each other he hit the
ground that is a feasible mechanism for
an injury
two the acute injury characteristics so
there's two symptoms
one loss of consciousness now he's
reporting five to ten minutes of loss of
consciousness based on all of the
available evidence that is improbable
and I can go into that more but you've
probably heard a lot about that but my
opinion is that if he suffered a loss of
consciousness it was seconds not minutes
okay the duration of loss of
consciousness is important because the
longer the loss of consciousness the
more severe the injury okay so we're the
it is my opinion that there was seconds
of loss of consciousness Consciousness
if at all and then um
by the time the EMT Whitney Smith
arrived she described some mild
disorientation
which was kind of a rattled response to
this unexpected Collision on the on the
ski hill there wasn't any gross
confusion or any other significant
mental status changes and then of course
he was complaining of rip pain so we've
got the disorientation he was seen at
Park City InstaCare two hours post
injury and at that point he was
complaining of a slight headache rib
pain and I think a dullness in his head
um but the the provider there very
specifically documented no signs or
symptoms of concussion there were no
clear signs like dizziness nausea of
vomiting any double or blurry vision any
of the really classic symptoms of a
significant concussive injury
the next day he was seen at the VA and
at the VA he is only reporting again a
slight headache and rib pain and
irritability
again no other significant signs of an
acute concussive injury
in the two to three weeks after that the
only person that really saw him was his
girlfriend and in her deposition all she
described was that he was really grouchy
and didn't really want to be touched and
that he was in pain she is also not
describing any significant symptoms now
I know she's not a medical professional
but the absence of her description of
other symptoms is notable
and then we've got some really important
objective indices of injury so as we had
started to mention before lunch
one month post injury he underwent an
extensive battery of tests that assessed
multiple aspects of attention
now attention is the cognitive domain
that is the most sensitive to concussion
and he performed consistently and above
average range on measures of sustained
attention complex sustained attention
divided attention alternating attention
and selective attention so very clearly
no objective indices of attention
deficits
then one month later so two months post
injury he had a similar extensive
battery looking at multiple aspects of
memory same thing no deficits
lastly and not lastly but uh in May
which is about two and a half months
post injury he had a thorough vestibular
evaluation
and so the balance system is actually
really sensitive to concussion such that
even healthy fit 20 year old athletes
will have impaired impaired balance when
they are concussed
so Mr sanderson's balance was described
as exceptional there was no evidence of
vestibular dysfunction or balance
problems
so that's another really important
objective in index of his brain
functioning
lastly
um
about a week and a half after the injury
Mr Sanderson reported a markedly
increased intake of alcohol he reported
to his primary care that he was drinking
five to six drinks a week five to six
drinks two to three times a week which
is actually a quite significant amount
of alcohol
and there's one thing about concussion
is that one of the telltale signs is
reduced tolerance to alcohol
such that when people are acutely
concussed if they drink alcohol more
often than not they report feeling ill
or they get really intoxicated off of a
fraction of the alcohol that they
normally drink
most people do not enjoy drinking
alcohol when they're concussed and so
all of when I put all of that evidence
together
sure it's possible that he had a mild
concussion but at most it was mild and
by by May there really isn't any strong
ongoing evidence of clear brain injury
is it possible that he did not have a
concussion
it's possible
you mentioned in that answer the
objective measures that were taken in
valuations following the accident how
would you
evaluate the discrepancy that there
might be between objective measures and
a subjective report that that vary you
know and maybe that just for the jury's
sake and I can clarify my question the
patient is reporting certain experience
of symptoms versus an objective finding
through some sort of assessment
well
well it's hard to make sense of and and
there there could be many things but one
of one of the most prominent things that
was very clear is that his anxiety went
Sky High after this injury
um his blood pressure was through the
roof he was calling or he was emailing
his providers saying I'm having a
hypertension crisis he was doubling his
medication and it wasn't helping so it
was very clear that he was experiencing
a lot of anxiety and anxiety can
certainly Drive perception of of a lot
of these difficulties
did you note a record a few weeks prior
to the ski Collision that included Mr
sanderson's report that he was feeling
old all of a sudden
that's in her report
because I haven't seen it
she's overruled she's have you reviewed
that record I definitely have and um
does it play into your evaluation of
where post-accident symptoms might be
coming from it plays into me trying to
understand where he is now now and
there's been a lot of talk about Decline
and some of those records offer some
telltale signs that I see in older
adults that decline is starting to
happen so there's a line in there that
describes that he's overwhelmed with
paperwork and trying to get things
organized and he's he's I can't remember
the exact line but those are the kinds
of things that I'm listening for when
I'm evaluating older adults because
these the those those are the behavioral
signs that functional changes are
starting to happen in someone's life
okay great let's go to your second
opinion here
just a second to pull it up
as I pull it up
you can read it
misses both yeah
plaintiff's course and evolution of
self-reported symptoms is inconsistent
with the known trajectory of concussion
related symptoms
so why would you say that so the thing
with with brain injury is that the
symptoms are worse in the beginning and
then they gradually improve now that
rate Improvement can vary greatly among
individuals and some people might
experience some plateaus along the way
but
brain injury does not progressively
worsen
and Mr Sanderson was reporting when he
saw
Dr Fung in 2017 about a year and a half
after his injury and then Dr Goldstein
in 2020 he was reporting new symptoms
that weren't present in those first
three months and he was describing a
worsening of symptoms and I think many
of his family members are under the
impression that things are worsening so
a worsening in 2017 and 2020 cannot be
attributed with any medical probability
to a concussion a mild concussion in
2016.
and maybe so the jury has a sense of the
new symptoms that you're describing what
are those in particular um he was
describing neck pain
and a lot more
just general dysfunction I can't
remember all the symptoms off hand sure
what what symptoms would you attribute
to the a concussion if in fact he did
have one in the ski Collision
well again there really isn't any strong
evidence of symptoms in those first
three months he wasn't even really he
was reporting difficulties with his
thinking skills but yet on objective
test he was performing normally so
it's difficult to separate what was
anxiety during that period and what was
true concussive deficits but I think
another piece is that even one of his
daughters said one of his daughters saw
him in May I believe for for her
graduation and described him as feeling
kind of slow and dull not as engaged as
usually is
and that could certainly be a symptom of
concussion but even she said that that
fully resolved and he has since returned
back to his ex extroverted self and so
again that's the known trajectory that I
would expect for a concussive injury but
not a new or worsening symptoms years
later
thank you let's move to your third
opinion unless there's anything to add I
think that's suffice thank you so number
three will you read that for us
plaintiff's medical history is notable
for a number of comorbid conditions that
better explain reported course of
decline
and why do you say that
so as a neuropsychologist
a really thorough medical history is
essential to understanding the context
that of the person of the brain that I'm
evaluating and there are a number of
medical conditions that are known to
increase risk of premature cognitive
decline as one ages or risk for
developing dementia okay so there's this
is a really important piece so the
biggest and most important one is the
topic that we've been discussing today
is this abnormal brain MRI okay a
grossly abnormal structural
abnormalities on his brain there's
there's volume loss there's enlarged
ventricles there's microvascular
ischemic disease
so there's a lot of problems here
if you were in the courtroom and Dr
Black was talking about the Imaging this
the same thing he was talking about yes
and so that that brain MRI alone
and no other information that MRI alone
predicts problems as he ages it is a
question of when not if
and again going back to what you know
you mentioned the medical records three
weeks prior to this Collision again like
there's subtle evidence that decline was
happening and and and and I can talk
about
well maybe that's getting done I'm
jumping ahead that's another we'll get
there I'm sure okay so
um so the MRI that's that's a huge red
flag for me as a neuropsychologist okay
no he's got a lot of other medical
issues
and I'll briefly go through these okay
so he was diagnosed with sleep apnea in
2003 sleep apnea is a disorder where one
stops breathing for short episodes
repeatedly through the night the
consequence of that is that there's when
you stop breathing your the blood oxygen
levels go down reduced oxygen is not
good for your brain and over time that
causes problems untreated sleep apnea
alone will cause cognitive decline over
time and most importantly it's also
associated with fatigue and headaches
and
most prominently attention and executive
dysfunction
okay so
um he was unable to tolerate the CPAP
machine and so that went untreated he
also has chronic insomnia
we know
there's no Foundation she's not a
medical doctor
um
you can't speculate about what these
means of a medical
assistant I think I think she qualified
her answer as to what it meant to her as
a neuropsychologist so for that limited
purpose I'll allow the evidence thank
you your honor and if I made Dr
Eastfield I want to just make sure I'm
following these the the medical history
that you point to that might better
explain or that does better explain Mr
sanderson's post accident symptoms
includes the pre-accident Imaging that
you've discussed this the untreated
sleep apnea and now I believe we were
going on to a third one but I because of
the objection I cannot recall there's a
there's a a list so again kind of
getting a very clear picture of what his
pre-injury status is okay so these are
the ones that I'm going through are all
risk factors from a neuropsychological
perspective and so chronic insomnia we
know that chronic insomnia is is a risk
factor for developing dementia and what
happens when the brain goes into deep
sleep there's a cleanup function that
happens and
um there's a clean cleanup of abnormal
proteins and plaques that shouldn't be
there and so when the brain is not
getting into those deep stages of sleep
that cleanup function is not happening
and over time this will cause problems
and uh kind of in the lungs alongside
that because of this insomnia he's been
treated with sedatives and
benzodiazepines since at least 2004. we
know that long-term use of those
medications is associated with a
markedly elevated risk of developing
dementia
he also has restless leg syndrome
restless leg syndrome is another risk
factor for dementia when it occurs in
older adults it's often an early warning
sign of emerging functional behavioral
changes that are associated with
dementia
he has chronic migraines
in my and his migraines were quite
severe in 2011 and 12 he was reporting
up to three a day
chronic migraines are associated with
the microvascular ischemic disease on
the brain
he also has hypertension and high
cholesterol these are also
cardiovascular risk factors that
adversely affect the blood flow reduce
blood flow is bad for your brain and
over time what can cause problems
sorry to interrupt you you can finish I
think you've been talking about physical
symptoms here or physical conditions at
this point correct were there any mental
health conditions okay
a lot of medical issues that would
increase that would suggest an increased
risk of decline then we've also got a
lot of psychiatric issues he has been
struggling with chronic anxiety and
depression since
um the 90s and he's been medicated for
that since the 90s and we know that
chronic mood disorders is another risk
factor for decline as we age
now the anxiety is actually really
important
um
Mr Sanderson underwent a full
neuropsychological evaluation in 2017
just about a little over one year after
this injury and
um like his earlier testing this
neuropsych evaluation was completely
unremarkable with no evidence of
residual brain injury and it was her
conclusion that anxiety was a big factor
here and in fact this second
neuropsychological evaluation was sought
out for Mr sanderson's report because he
just had a friend pass away from early
onset dementia and he was a little he
was worried and so the neuropsychologist
felt that anxiety was playing a big role
in his perceived in this thing called
democracy and what we stand for to
really consider whether this is the kind
of country that we want to live in or
deliver to our children
Sky News snow reports sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk
[Music]
on my ski hire in Europe
while recent snowfall has brought some
excellent skiing at high levels in the
Alps but there's still a concern there
any other aspects of Dr goldstein's
evaluation that gives support to your
opinion
yes if we could bring up that executive
function table one more time that would
be great sure
and this
is
exhibit plaintiff's exhibit 43. yeah
thank you
okay so you'll feel look
um that working memory that very bottom
line there again this is Mr sanderson's
subjective reports this is just his
complaints he's reporting really
significant working memory problems
on Mr Gold's or Dr goldstein's testing
he exhibited exceptional working memory
so on objective tests he was performing
in the high average range and his
working memory index which is a an
average of two scores was at the 87th
percentile
so this is a really great example how
perception does not equal reality
and are there any other aspects of Dr
goldstein's evaluation that helps
support your opinion and so um Dr
Goldstein made a conclusion that based
on extensive personality testing that Mr
Sanderson was a well-adjusted adult but
his own data does not support that and
so if you could bring up that next the
Milan table oh sure I believe
this is
rub this down
pages
27 and 28
of
Dr goldstein's
evaluation which for plaintiffs you're
on a week we object to this this is not
predisclosed
it's not an admitted exhibit we had no
notice that this was coming
so that's unfair
why don't you approach the bench
uh Dr Goldstein uh would it be useful
we've been talking about Dr Goldstein
yes we have
um
would it be helpful for you to look at
the that page the evaluation page
um the data and goldstein's evaluation
that you were talking about would it
refresh your recollection of that data
okay if I provide that to you we'll talk
through it but we won't publish it to
the jury okay
well I actually don't need to see it if
you want me to just talk about it if
we're not going to show them sure that
would be great okay so
um
Dr Goldstein administered a long
questionnaire that assesses how one
thinks feels and behaves it's a measure
of personality and on this measure of
Personality Mr sanderson's responses
indicated a very high level of
generalized anxiety along with that was
also a very high elevation of what we
call
somatic symptoms meaning that there's a
high focus or preoccupation on health
and physical symptoms when we see high
anxiety and symptoms
um what's it it's symptom I forget the
title of the
um
remember that it's a symptom disorder or
something like this when you see them
together there's a high rate of
somatization somatization is when
psychological distress manifests as
physical symptoms so as a
neuropsychologist this is always
something that I'm looking out for
because it can certainly help me
understand
their presentation and their reported
complaints additionally as part of this
evaluation or part of this questionnaire
there's a number of personality traits
that are measured and Mr Sanderson
scored extremely high on narcissism and
specifically the
of his responses within that category
suggest somebody who might be um
feel that he is superior he may feel
that he lacks empathy he may lack
empathy he might have an egocentric
perspective on life not see things from
other people's perspectives he may
expect special favors or special
treatment
along that there are additional skills
that were elevated there was a
a
histrionic scale where he was extremely
dramatic and expressive other
characteristics that go with that scale
are volatile overreactive explosive
and then there was also some skills that
indicated that he was he was a 10 he's
someone that likes and needs attention
and approval
data that you're going over
tell you anything about the executive
function chart we were looking at in the
self-reporting that that we get from Mr
Sanderson there
no personality by itself doesn't
necessarily correlate with executive
function or dysfunction
um
people who have high anxiety executive
functions is kind of a funny construct
because it can be people can have
executive dysfunction for a lot of
reasons some of them could be neurologic
and some of them can be Psychiatric so
most people with serious psychiatric
disorders evidence some degree of
executive dysfunction you can also have
executive dysfunction if you're sleep
deprived or stressed so it's it's again
it's it's an interesting concept it's
not necessarily it can be many things
can affect it
do you have any opinions about whether
Mr Sanderson has
exhibits any somaticization
well that's a that's a medical diagnosis
it's actually a psychological diagnosis
overruled
and obviously one of my questions is
going to be explained to us what that
term means so what was the answer to my
question yeah
well I mean that
that why he's expressing all these
symptoms but there isn't actually
objective evidence of these symptoms so
he's describing balance problems but on
testing he performs exceptionally he's
describing having all these cognitive
problems but on cognitive testing he
performs well so
um somatization is one thing that helps
somebody make sense of what what he's
experiencing and understanding his
presentation
and then is it unprofessional of you to
render these opinions without having
seen Mr Sanderson
well importantly I'm not I'm not Mr
sanderson's neuropsychologist he's not
my patient I'm not treating him or
making any medical decisions if that
were the case then of course I would
need to see him but again I was just
hired to look at the records and provide
opinions on the facts in the records and
do you feel
um
confident in your opinions despite
having not evaluated him
I do
sorry what was the answer sorry I I do
feel confident in my opinions
because the facts are the facts and
again that that injury characteristics
in those first few days and first few
months are that's the objective data
that's the most important time period to
look at and and the facts are there okay
that's all the questions for now thank
you
yeah
thank you Mr Egan thank you Mr Sykes are
you the question
uh Dr eastbound how much have you been
paid in total
do this records review and come today
for your testimony
I don't know I I don't I didn't review
my invoices
you've come to court in an important
trial
and you can't tell the jury how much
you've been paid for your testimony
six and a half hours
and
I want to say 20 hours I'm not 100 sure
is it is it more or less than twenty
thousand dollars
more or less than 15.
ten thousand
okay
now
um
let me
uh
ask you about that first thing the last
thing you mentioned
uh
it's important is it not
if you're going to render an opinion
about somebody like you have today
a lot of
negative or contrary opinions about
Terry Sanderson right
in other words uh he's maybe got
dementia
he's somaticizing his problems
and you've rendered those opinions have
you not
without ever
examining the patient correct
I have not rendered any specific
opinions that he has dementia or
somatization disorder I'm merely
describing Dr goldstein's results and
offering
they're not dying I'm not offering
diagnoses well
uh you sure fooled me on that one
because I thought I heard a lot of
diagnoses
but since you're not rendering diagnosis
okay not rendering diagnosis
let's talk about what you are doing
um
could you is appropriate is responsible
for a neuropsychologist to comment
on somebody without actually seeing them
clinically in the office
again if he was my patient yes he's not
my patient I was hired to review records
and provide opinions on the facts and
the records aren't there standards with
the American Psychological Association
that recommend that you see someone
before rendering opinions on them those
ethical principles apply to clinical
practice and patient doctor
relationships with which does not apply
in this situation so you don't have the
same ethical principles
in this case that you would if he was
your patient is that the idea
the principles it applies to clinical
care this isn't clinical care okay do
you agree
that if you're going to evaluate
someone
and then come before a jury and tell us
about him
that's better to have more information
or less information about them what do
you think
more information or less information
okay
you get more information if you actually
have a clinical
interview with someone
as a neuropsychologist my job is to
evaluate for brain injury and he had had
numerous neuropsychological evaluations
and there that none of which have found
evidence of brain injury and so a fourth
neuropsychological evaluation wasn't
going to uncover brain injury that
nobody else uncovered so there was no
point in me providing another evaluation
okay
so you're saying that you wouldn't have
gotten any more information that would
be helpful in doing a clinical interview
with him or clinical testing right well
again he had been previously seen by
three neurons
three different neuropsychologists who
all did the same interview that I
probably would have done and so I had
most of the information that I would
have requested in addition to 20 years
of medical history do you have any idea
why each one of the
six
defense experts not no one
did a clinical interview with him do you
know why
I did not okay
is your request a clinical interview
we discussed it and again I felt there
was no point in doing another interview
because he had had or another evaluation
because he'd had so many and they all
came to the same conclusion no evidence
of brain injury and anxiety was a major
factor now
you have two other cases with my Law
Firm is that correct two other cases
your Law Firm
two other cases objection I'm not aware
of this one in St George right
well you did a two-day
clinical interview
on a guy who had his eye shot out by a
cop
remember that one relevance system
sustained hey
and you have another one and another ski
case
on Deer Valley and did a two-day
interview on him remember that same
objection
sustained
on what grounds relevance okay well
isn't it true
that you do a lot of work
and in your current situation for
defense attorneys
trying to defeat brain injury cases is
that a fair statement
no 80 of my work is pointed plaintiff
really uh okay so but you do do a fair
amount of Defense work don't you
in the criminal Realm
most of my work is defense in the Civil
realm most of my work is plaintiff are
you aware that all you have to do
to get a clinical interview with someone
on a legal case is requested because the
judge is almost never turned it down are
you aware of that
in the foundation legal determination
sustained okay
well
uh have you had any other well uh how
many cases have you had in the past five
years where you've been turned down for
a a a rule 35 independent medical
examination you had any I wasn't hired
to do an independent medical exam in
this case I was hired as a consultant
that said those other cases I was hired
as an and I was at hired to perform an
evaluation because neither of them had a
prior evaluation okay have you had
anybody turn you down if you've asked
think of it's never come up never come
up okay
now excuse me
as a neuropsychologist
you surely recognize the importance in
the evaluation process
okay
of finding out
how the person function
before the incident which is February
26th
2016 and after right
yes okay
now
you can get some of that information by
asking
the injured person himself or herself
can't you
in this case she didn't have that
opportunity
but
you had other information did you not a
lot of it let me finish the question
please and other information about the
before and after status
of Terry Sanderson is that a true
statement
I had a lot of information yes
well
on page two of your report do you have
that in handy there yes
you had
the depositions
of Polly Sanderson
Terry's daughter
and Carlene Davidson
his former girlfriend
essentially a fiancee did you read those
two
I did you did
okay
um it's not my understanding that they
were engaged
well do you remember Polly saying on
Polly uh Carlene saying
that she was living up here 300 days out
of a year
and they were together about
a year and a half before they actually
remember that
I remember that they spent a lot of time
together I was under the impression that
it was split more between St George and
Salt Lake oh really okay
uh and that's what you took out of the
deposition
then it was split
yeah actually it's an irrelevant factor
for me irrelevant because I knew that
they spent a lot of time together and
that's all that mattered are you telling
this jury of the good people
of Summit County
that what
a girlfriend was essentially live in
says is irrelevant
for before and after is that what you're
saying that's not what I'm saying sounds
like it that's not what I said now are
you aware that Carlene Davidson
testified
that there was a night and day
difference
between Terry Sanderson before and after
this ski crash the winner then
I do okay
did you simply disregard that because I
don't see any reference
to Carlene Davidson
in your five-page reporter on a single
reference
why did you omit that
so Carlene spent some time with him in
that initial recovery period and she
described that he was grouchy and didn't
want to be touched and that was pretty
much it and then she then he withdrew
from the relationship he became hyper
focused on his symptoms and himself and
he withdrew from the relationship and
she was
heartbroken and
and then they they didn't really spend a
lot of time together after that so so
your testimony is
that all Carlene Davidson said about
changes afterwards is that he was
grouchy
he was recovering for
him
it's but it's it it's relevant in that
you know he pulled away and he was
focused on getting better and and
dealing with his health and he didn't
want to engage so like he's had a
physical Orthopedic injury that he was
nursing and
that could certainly could explain some
of the not wanting to go out and do
things
he's a simple country lawyer okay I'm
gonna try that question again
are you telling this jury
that I think you said essentially that's
all he said he said was he was grouchy
are you telling this jury of the people
of Summit County
that all Carlene Davidson noted
indifference was that he was grouchy is
that what you're saying
in the first couple of weeks that's my
recall of the deposition first couple of
weeks okay but she was with him for six
months six months
after that accident after that crash
it's my understanding each other first
question
and didn't she say
that
changed in a wide variety of ways
socially personality change executive
function
emotions
didn't she say that and you ignored it
she might have said it but importantly
Milo concussions don't produce gross
changes in personality social
functioning or behavior okay
now Sam Goldstein you know right I do
he's one of the world's foremost experts
in neuropsychology correct
it's written dozens of books on
children's neuropsychology not just
children's okay
do you think that executive function
test is for children
no but it's not one widely used in an
adult clinical practice okay
uh he disagrees by the way I talked to
him in the noon hour okay he may come
back tomorrow and
sustained
um
isn't it true
that that test
is one of the two
top tennis used worldwide
to assess executive function
that is not my opinion I would disagree
with that
no
do you understand
from Carlene Davidson
that she stayed she's stuck in that for
six months with Terry
understand that
I believe that's probably it is your
testimony that just a second what did
you say I believe that it was probably
about six months my understanding as
they broke up at the late summer early
fall is it your understanding that they
broke up simply because he was cranky is
that your understanding
I understand is that he
bar
my question was is it your understanding
that they broke up simply because he was
cranky
that is not my understanding good okay
so let's go on
you uh
did you read the deposition
a polygression
his daughter did you by any chance watch
your testimony here in Toronto I did not
okay
uh
isn't it true
that polygrass would hurt in that
position
said much the same thing as Carlene
Davidson that there was a massive sudden
dramatic decline
and her father
after that ski crash
true or false
I believe that she said that but my
understanding is that I didn't get a
clear sense that she had a clear picture
of her father's functioning in the
months to year before this accident when
she referred to previous functioning she
always referred to when he was working
which was before 2010 so it was a long
time ago and arguably an unfair
comparison
okay
have you ever ever read a Hamlet
you think that she protest us too much
my simple question
okay
did Polly Sanderson
say that there was a massive
fundamental and dramatic decline in her
father after the ski crash
now try to get me a non-handled answer
yes or no
so I
I read all three daughters depositions
and I have a hard time keeping straight
who exactly said what I know that they
all described some changes after the
accident
two of them felt that
there were
significant changes one of them felt
that there was a lot of the same
behaviors before this but they were just
magnified after the concussion and one
of them noted that there were some
significant changes but a lot of it
improved and then a whole different set
of behaviors really emerged so
so you can't answer my question about
what Polly Sanderson said then
a lot of changes problem is in clinical
practice I see this with
time so with older adults it's really
tricky because many older adults are
experiencing some degree of decline
unfortunately that's just part of aging
and then when you've got a complex
medical history it's more probable and a
concussion like this might happen in the
patient and the family grab onto this
concussion as the defining factor that
changed everything and they
Miss remember or under represent their
pre-injury functioning and overestimate
their problems after this and everything
gets tied to the concussion and so I
that's what I saw happening with this
family is that everyone's really grabbed
on to including Mr Sanderson that this
concussion is was the cause of
everything and the behavioral
presentation that he and his family are
describing is inconsistent with a mild
concussive injury and very consistent
with with what I would predict based on
his medical history and so again yes
they are describing a lot of changes
after this concussion but
I can't rely on them
to
clearly indicate a causal relationship
with this concussion because I don't
think that they were carefully
observing and aware of his level of
functioning in the year prior to this no
so Jerry understands
that was a two-minute answer to a very
simple question
tell me what poly uh
what what Paulie Harris said I'm sorry
Polly Gresham
and you gave me a two-minute
queen of Denmark answer now now why did
you feel a need
to add all that detail when the question
was very simple
why
because it's important for the jury to
understand I don't want them to be
misled
all right so
you can't really tell the jury because
you either don't remember you didn't
read it you can't tell the jury
what what uh Polly Grafton said about
the dramatic changes
right instead of telling me yeah you can
tell me yes or no you know that you give
me a two-minute answer is that what
happened here
the changes that were described were
changes such as
severe disorganization getting lost in
the details
ruminative thinking obsessive thinking
gross disorganization confusion getting
lost
none of these are symptoms of concussion
okay now let me ask you this you uh
you talked about
the concerns about these MRIs now you're
not a medical doctor but you say you
look at them right they're an important
piece of my
testimony this morning I did yeah
excuse me he said did he not
that
from 2009
the 2021
all the MRI she saw there's no change
did you hear that testimony
I did no change so
this testimony you gave the jury about
being worried about him
you know this explains he's getting
worse because of this there's no
evidence of that in these scans is there
the structural changes are not worsening
and if I'm going to go ahead and add
that it you know it was it's pretty
miraculous if he wasn't having more
significant problems back in 2009 and it
was just a matter of when not if and so
I wouldn't predict that more structural
changes needed to happen for him to
actually start manifesting symptoms of
that okay now break into their two and a
half minute answer let me just ask you
this can you look in those records
and she were any physician
not yourself you're not a physician has
diagnosed
those conditions
that many people have
asymptomatically or anybody diagnosed
those conditions is causing these
current problems
they're by the books before you open
them up I didn't understand them could
you repeat that question please yeah
show me a record
we're a physician now he had many
at the VA right yes many not just
Physicians but speech pathologists
psychologists
neuropsychiatrists who are MPS
and no one
at the VA
diagnose what you're saying is the case
did they
I'm not diagnosing anything well you're
saying that these these scans
explain his problems but no medical
doctor has done that
now how can you diagnose it and you
didn't see him and no medical doctor has
done it now explain that to a simple
country lawyer the medical doctors have
all noted it's repeatedly been stated
that his brain MRI looks like he has
normal pressure hydrocephalus is there a
diagnosis
no has he ever been diagnosed with
normal pressure hydrocephalus ever he
hasn't because
typically the diagnosis requires
clinical correlation with a Triad of
symptoms that involves a very specific
characteristic changing gait and
confusion they don't have to have
dementia but cognitive changes and
urinary incontinence now they say he's
asymptomatic
I'm not convinced because the most uh
common mood symptom associated with
normal pressure hydrocephalus is this
lack of energy lack of motivation low
drive and he's been reporting this for
decades let me snap you there would it
be accurate to say
that you have a better handle
on what these pre-existing uh problems
that are identified have cost him then
his medical doctors at the VA is that a
fair State no I'm not saying I have a
better handle than any of his medical
disorders but as a neuropsychologist I
have a very unique perspective and I'm
the one that puts together neurologic
data and psychological data that's my
expertise and that would be an important
piece that I would take into
consideration if I were evaluating him
myself okay now let me ask you about
executive function
I look through your report
and again I'm a simple country lawyer
but I can read
I don't see any reference in your report
to Executive function anywhere
am I missing anything
now executive function is not commonly
that's a yes or no that's a yes or no
no
let's talk about
faking and malingering
are you suggesting that Terry is faking
this
these problems for money is is that your
suggestion
no there's no no and it's a faking
and it's genuinely distressed now you
say that in your report
that uh
your diagnosis is somaticization
disorders is that what I'm reading here
no I did not diagnose him
well you mentioned you say on
Page Six
somedicization may also explain the late
onset or worsening the plants reported
symptoms
your words somatization is used more
like a noun there
it's not a diagnosis okay that's what
you wrote
and some manetization so the jury
understands it
I don't need a two-minute answer it's a
very short answer tell the jury what it
means somatization is when psychological
distress
manifests as physical symptoms now has
any physician
psychologist or anybody else diagnosed
Terry Sanderson with some monetization
disorder anybody
that I know of
but they all repeatedly talk about his
anxiety and anxiety about his health and
his symptoms and his preoccupation on
his symptoms
thank you Captain under two minutes
okay
argumentative
withdrawn okay
you don't remember to take one minute
and just talk to my uh
I'm their capitalist running dog I gotta
go talk to him
all right thank you Mr Egan
Dr eastvold after
questioning from plaintiff is it still
your opinion that plaintiff suffered at
most a mild concussion from the
Collision
occurring on February 26 2016. that's an
improper redirect that's already been
going into overruled
yes that my opinion remains
and is it still your opinion that
plaintiff's course and evolution of
self-reported symptoms is inconsistent
with the known trajectory of concussion
related symptoms yes
and is it still your opinion that
plaintiff's medical history is notable
for a number of cool comorbid conditions
that better explain his reported course
of decline yes
no further questions can I add something
please
sure go ahead okay
I have a lot of compassion for Mr
Sanderson I do believe that things are
changing for him it is terrifying when
one starts to lose their faculties and
there's that I'm not I object to this
sustainable unresponsive thank you it's
it's a narrative I you know if you've
got some more questions go ahead
um
I think we can be done
okay okay no further questions
thank you
Mr Egan yeah you're only your honor we
call Dr gallet askanazi as an expert
judge you want to take a short break
it's been an hour it has been an hour
let's take a short recess
short recess
thank you
foreign
ready for the jury
all right why don't you let him know
where the lawyers approach the bench
please
thank you
thank you Mr Owens you may proceed
James is back up oh Jay Mr Egan thank
you your honor we call Dr gleet askanazi
do you swear that the testimony you were
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truths to help you
God
thank you
good afternoon
would you begin once you get seated give
your full name and spell it
my name is galit Ashkenazi
g-a-l-i-t last name a-s-k-e-n-a-z-i
Dr askanazi thank you for being here
let's begin by asking you what you see
your role as an expert here today
so I was asked to review records of Mr
Sanderson in order to determine if due
to the ski accident he suffered any
cognitive or mental health issues and if
he did so to what extent
we approached the bench I think it's
made
[Music]
okay
here are the time the time for that
bench conference can we have asserted to
the plaintiff
I'll take that under advisement thank
you
enrolled
um it's under advisement right now
because it's a pending objection based
on what's going on with the questioning
next question I was going to ask you was
particular look at Dr Fong's assessment
of Mr Sanderson yes I was asked to
specifically look at cognitive effects
and Dr Fong's assessment and his
treatment while he was there okay
okay
um
and
we'll just start with the main point do
you agree with Dr Kong's assessment
in terms of persistent post-concussive
syndrome no I do not
and why do you have expertise to be able
to offer that opinion
okay are you asking about like to start
with my education yeah sure you can give
us your background yeah um so I
completed my undergraduate degree at
Princeton in Psychology I then spent two
years after that working at Harvard
Medical School and Mass General Hospital
assessing dementia and doing uh work in
the diagnostic clinic there
I then completed both my masters and PhD
in Clinical Psychology at Case Western
Reserve University which is in Cleveland
it's a general clinical degree but I
specialize in neuropsychology I created
my for myself my own training
experiences in neuropsychology
I then spent a year as a neuropsychology
intern at the VA in Cleveland for my
pre-doctoral internship
and then after I graduated I completed a
two-year postdoctoral Fellowship a
residency in clinical neuropsychology in
accordance of what we call the Houston
guidelines
it dictates how you have to finish two
years of supervised training with a
board-certified clinical
neuropsychologist and how it's required
that you continue your education so you
have more expertise and then complete an
examination with that and then once I
finished all that formal education I got
board certified in clinical
neuropsychology which is a few year
process there's a few steps to it we're
in examination samples oral examination
and then I re-specialized in forensic
psychology I did an internship or
postdoctoral Fellowship in forensic
psychology and I also got board
certified in forensic psychology
I'm currently one of six people in the
country with those dual certifications
in
your opinion did Dr Fong
sufficiently assess Mr sanderson's
medical condition in history to render
the opinion that she did about his
persistent post-concussive symptoms
no and as people have already said today
and I don't want to be too redundant in
order to assess a concussion first and
foremost you need to know the symptoms
of the time it's considered an acute and
immediate condition so you need to know
the symptoms at the time
then to establish if someone has
post-concussive syndrome you actually
have to show the path from the
concussion to those symptoms that a
person is claiming
Dr Fong reviewed absolutely no medical
records even though this was a legal
referral to her
um
she took at face value his report that
he'd been having certain symptoms for a
year and a half straight which we know
through the medical records that is not
true at all he had some symptoms at the
beginning completely resolved and then
actually his records after that show
full resolution with multiple of course
neuropsychological testings during that
time
and are you familiar with Dr Fong's
testimony that
um
that as I believe it uh if I'm
remembering it correctly that
the defense experts which would include
you don't um
recognize post-concussive persistent
post-concussive symptoms
so post-concussive syndrome is a
well-known condition but the thing is
its symptoms overlap with overlaps with
multiple other conditions and that's why
you have to connect it back to the acute
concussion now the term persistent
post-concussive syndrome is one that's
considered in the neuropsychology
Community to be one that's under
research there's no real evidence that
after three months a person continues to
have symptoms from her concussion or a
mild traumatic brain injury so that's
still under investigation if those
symptoms are truly persistent
so Dr Fong as you said did not review
prior records but did you review prior
records I reviewed the records of from
around the time
I reviewed 15 years of medical records
beforehand and as many of the medical
records given to me afterwards as well
as some of the reports associated with
the accident and you have your own
opinions about that prior medical
history and how it might relate to Dr
Fong's diagnosis is that right yes
that's correct especially because when
you're talking about any acute condition
you need to know what are the changes
from before to after to say well this
acute condition caused those changes
possibly and as I understand it you've
created some slides that go over some of
those opinions is that correct yes so I
created slides that summarize the
records of I reviewed and the
information I thought that was relevant
to form my opinions and
on to Dr phone yes and so with that your
honor I moved to admit and or to publish
to the jury as a demonstrative exhibit
defense exhibit
105 is a through
uh another letter I gotta go to the end
here
a through
V as in vehicle see
Victor yeah Victor yeah okay any
objection to defense exhibit 105 answer
be on for demons or purposes that have
any objections other than those that
have already been voiced I haven't been
pushed any objections to it but
it's undisclosed
so we've never seen they could have
shown this this earlier this week yeah
so are these are these demonstratives
that were they provided under the
pre-trial order they were they were
provided before before the deadline
these slides yes
all right you're your honor I wonder if
you could show me where where you've
provided them to the other side so we
can move on Beyond this sure
yes one of the plaintiff's side come up
here so they can you can take a look at
this
these are the March 16th ones yeah
judge I see these in the document but
they were disclosed I think late
incorrectly
take a look at what just came over there
because
they were never identified as coming
from her just doctor well let me let me
ask you this Mr Sykes do you want to
take trial time up to to nail this down
well give me those 10 seconds then
thank you
December 31st we'll let it go
ahead okay
the RBC for demonstrative purposes only
to help this witness illustrate her
testimony and your honor can I have that
delay of time attributed to the
plaintiff please yes you may okay Dr
askanazi I'm gonna pull put your slides
up here
putting them there
to connect
apologize for the delay I don't know why
it keeps doing this
works and then it won't work
um
Dr Ashkenazi while it's coming up so we
don't waste time oh there it is
uh are these are slides that we were
just discussing yes they are okay great
um and let's let's go into the first
slide which is Mr sanderson's mental
health history you know a number of
things but I would like to focus on some
things that maybe have not been covered
okay including Mr sanderson's mental
health history how it relates to his
emotions and relationships so if you
could discuss the mental health history
with that Focus
we just discussed that at the bench
overruled
some minor overlap but it doesn't seem
significant okay
okay go ahead do you remember the
question yes I do okay so I won't repeat
the known history of anxiety and
depression and again this is not
something that Dr Fong had assessed and
We Know It dates back decades
but very specifically he had sought
treatment in 2009 because he was having
relationship issues both with his family
and in other relationships that he
described as a conflictual interactional
style that got him into trouble he
described that he is someone who likes
to be in control and he gets frustrated
when he's not and these were in the
treatment records as to why he was
seeking out treatment at that time
got it
um
did you have did you know in his history
any significant anger issues
uh I it has been brought to my attention
that there was an issue that he punched
someone at some point who he believed
was in a relationship with his wife
there was also a restraining order so
the first one was beforehand and the
second one was in the last few years a
restraining order against him
um
see
I think we Dr Eastfield covered a couple
things there so we'll we'll move on
whoops sorry
here's the next slide it's still under
that same uh
a banner of Prior medical history
meaning before the accident correct yes
that's correct and in here you kind of
talk about medications which has not
really been discussed I don't believe in
too much detail what was significant to
you uh in the
pre-accident history in terms of Mr
sanderson's medications so we've already
talked about that he's long been on
medicines for depression anxiety and
insomnia but multiple times over the
years before this incident he tried to
get off the medications and every time
he tried to get off him his symptoms
would always rebound he'd have greater
depression greater anxiety couldn't
sleep and so it was a bit of a cycle
that he would get off and then need to
get back on it again
were these all being treated at the time
of the accident
so they were being treated but what's
interesting in his last visit with his
primary care physician right before the
accident the one that occurred on
February 2nd 2006. he actually informed
his doctor that he had taken himself off
his Wellbutrin which was his
antidepressant in the medicine that was
also helping control some of his anxiety
so you're talking with in a few weeks of
his accident he had disclosed that he
had taken himself off his medication
again
why was that significant in your
evaluation I found it significant
because the records beforehand showed
that he had always had a rebound when he
got off medication so some of his
reported mood changes in the months that
followed when he was still off the
medication could have been attributed to
not having it properly treated
did he do anything else aside from
take prescribed medications to deal with
his mental health issues
he did a lot of things he was in stress
management classes he looked into
Eastern philosophies into meditation
he did yoga he did a lot of different
things and had in attempts to help
better be stable
to supplement his medication but again
also to try to get off his medications
and were any of these things that he
tried medications or or the uh
um
the
um what would be the word the uh
non-medication treatment was any of that
successful so I'd refer to that as
adjunct therapies to the medication as
well
so they were successful but none of them
permanently so he always has cycled so
he'll be stable for a while and
sometimes even on medication he
destabilizes and he tends to do it when
there are family issues or relationship
issues or he has suffered an acute
medical issue
so why is that history significant to
the assessment
um
uh post accident in other words
what is significant about this history
for your opinions relating to his
concussion
so you want to know what
or how a person was functioning before
any major event you want to know did the
major event cause the changes or would
these be expected as sort of the normal
cycle of that individual
and what can you attribute to what
issues that you noted pre-accident did
they continue post-accident
they did now he did have an exacerbation
right after the accident he was in pain
he was on oxycodone his hypertension was
out of control he was irritable from the
pain and from the medication he was
feeling foggy because of it
and
he also of course was not on his
medication that he had discontinued
right beforehand so you do see a
flare-up of his mental health complaints
his anxiety especially but also was
excuse me his depression in the months
that followed but then you can also see
that by the end of July beginning of
August
he's back to his Baseline
see and when you say Baseline does that
mean where his mental health conditions
were before the accident exactly so it's
his Baseline not anyone else's so he
always had some chronic anxiety he'd
always had periods of depression the
insomnia persisted
so he was back to his Baseline so
starting about August 2016
you see that he doesn't have exceptional
complaints about flare-ups of anxiety
flare-ups of depression he actually has
no cognitive complaints starting in
August 2016 in his medical records
Beyond those that would be normal for
someone's age some minor forgetfulness
so that's important because you see that
there was an exacerbation and about five
months later his ribs are healed
he's off his Med he's off the pain
medication and he's back to his
pre-existing Baseline
in your review of Dr Fong's evaluation
she did not consider any of this that
you're discussing is that right no she
didn't seem to know that at all she
actually had documented that he reported
things like dizziness loss of balance
headaches
tension problems memory problems that
not only were present but had been
present the entire year and a half
prior to her seeing him which is medical
records show is not true
let's go to the next slide it's the
brain scan history I think this was
covered earlier by Dr Black were you in
the courtroom yes I was this has been
covered quite a bit
um but I'm not sure if this was
mentioned or not but the reason why he
had the brains ground was not actually
just because of that occlusion in his
retinal artery he had a flare-up of his
migraine headaches which he had suffered
from from his 30s or 40s and they were
checking his brain then and that's when
they found the normal pressure
hydrocephalus
um or found results they thought were
consistent with it but as you can see in
my note there there actually were no
cognitive complaints at that time
okay so here's the the next slide
relating
to the skiing incident of February 26
2016 and you were here for Dr
eastfield's testimony we don't want to
cover things that have been covered
already do you have any opinions uh that
would be new any new inside relating to
this particular incident and Mr
sanderson's symptoms the way it may have
contributed to those I absolutely agree
with everything the Dr eastvold said
about this
um I had also read a little bit more
about his claim of Amnesia of not
recalling what happened before and not
having formed those memories of what
happened before it was actually much
later that he started telling stories of
what he recalled but that was not there
initially he said he did not know what
happened that led to that accident
and then of course she had also
mentioned you know we talk about the
oxycodone he started drinking more he
was in pain and his blood pressure was
unstable right afterwards so those are
all things that occurred immediately
afterwards as well
you mentioned the telling of this
accident story and I'm wondering if you
might comment on the term confabulation
whether it's connected it has come up in
prior testimony is that something that
you know about so confabulation is a bit
different in a technical term in
neuropsychology we talk about
confabulation is people making things up
to fill in gaps you often see it in
Dementia
or you know
other type of neurological disorders
where they can't remember it it doesn't
seem to be a real confabulation I don't
know if there really was Amnesia or he
really did recall things
but I'm not going to Pine because
there's no real source of him to
confabulate that's not something you'd
see associated with a concussion
see a are there any other maybe related
notable
um
patterns that you see in Mr Sanderson
for example maybe embellishment
yes so he's very interesting because
sometimes he embellishes his medical
issues and sometimes he completely like
denies them or minimizes them they're
very extreme
the one issue that really comes to mind
is when he cut his calf with a box
opener he was opening a box and he ended
up cutting his calf and he needed
stitches for it
and he went to the ER and he got
stitches he had some concern in the week
that followed that he had maybe deep
vein thrombosis or apartment some
syndrome he went back to the ER they
said no you're fine
five years later he tells his doctor
that when he cut himself he cut his
femoral artery and almost bled to death
and that he's been having symptoms since
that time even though this is the very
first time in five years he's ever
mentioned it to his doctor he's been
seeing over the course of five years
so what does that tell you about
far beyond Dr Fung
I just saw to the at the bench just
duplicative testimony
overruled
so what what does an episode or a trait
like that tell you about Dr uh Mr
sanderson's symptoms after the accident
does it give you any insight as to
what's going on
well I think he himself best explained
it when he said that he has changed his
report of things based on the attention
he wants to get at the time
see okay let's go to the next slide
this is
record this is 105 F in case that's
helpful so again Dr Eastfield have
talked about the concussion but Dr Fong
also talks about the concussion and
you're aware for Testimony about it
correct yes and
um
is there anything that that we haven't
discussed already that you you'd like to
add in responding to Dr Fong's opinion
about that the relating the post
accident symptoms to a concussion
so the organization the leading
organization of clinical neuropsychology
in the country is the American Academy
of clinical neuropsychology
and in 2017 they published meta-analysis
of research meaning they looked at a lot
of research out there about
post-concussion syndrome
and what they found was that symptoms
associated with post-concussion syndrome
are actually more frequently reported in
individuals with mental health diagnoses
who've never even had a traumatic brain
injury than someone who's had a mild
traumatic brain injury with no other
conditions
so I think it's important to realize
that they're saying that once you hit
three months you really cannot use the
symptoms that are reported
to diagnose post-concussion syndrome you
really have to show the pathway from the
concussion to those complaints
and did you see any indication that Dr
Fong
was aware of those the study that you
just mentioned I mean this is
this was a compilation of many many
studies with thousands of actual
individuals associated with that study I
don't believe so I didn't see her
mention it whatsoever that she seemed to
be aware that they had published sort of
it was the leading Authority in clinical
neuropsychology had published this
information
we object to this this violates your
order on disclosure of medical
literature is going to be used whenever
you see this
has this been disclosed
this particular study right I believe
it's mentioned in the doctor askanathi's
report
okay overruled
did you note that Dr staying with
concussions for just a second did you
note that Dr Fong
um
offer testimony that studies are
actually showing that
there are increasing numbers of people
that have post concussion persistent
post-concussion symptoms
again that's still considered research
because it's hard for us to distinguish
this constellation of symptoms from
other conditions so whether or not it's
really due to the brain whether it's due
to mental health factors whether or not
there's something else going on it's
hard to know I am familiar with some
research that has looked into it and
they haven't controlled for things like
how many concussions has the person had
in what time frame
seen what would be the problem with your
results if you didn't control for that
kind of a thing so we know that if
someone suffers a second concussion when
they're still actively symptomatic from
the first one it will have an additive
effect it will actually make things
worse the symptoms worse and the
recovery longer
see
and let's go to the next slide here
this one you titled complicating factors
and you
um
discuss there's various things here but
I want to focus on the increased blood
pressure it I don't know that that's
been discussed very much what's notable
about the increase of blood pressure
in your mind so a few days after the
accident and he was prescribed the
oxycodone the second day
he contacts his doctor and he says my
blood pressure is really high I believe
he had assessed it at home at something
like 196 over 104 was it which is
exceptionally high and could be really
contributing to symptoms he followed up
with her the next day then he went in
and saw her the next week
and it's important because it can be
contributing to the symptoms of feeling
foggy or unwell or not like yourself
that's pretty high blood pressure
so uh was that blood pressure
contributing to symptoms Mr Sanderson
believed were connected to the
concussion in your mind
it appeared so yes
so let's go to the next slide oh
kind of going slow here so
okay so the next slide is early
cognitive assessments I believe Dr
eastfold covered these in her
testimonies that correct yes that is
correct
so I think we can
move on from those
unless you have anything to add that
that she didn't cover no
um
okay and then this 2017 cognitive
complaints I believe this also covers
things that that Dr Eastfield covered is
that correct it did but she didn't cover
the interim
so in the medical records between that
August 2016 and through that early April
2017. again he has not complaining
exceptionally about mental health
symptoms or cognitive symptoms
in the last time he sees his regular
doctor is February 13th in 2017. there
aren't complaints then it was only when
his friend dies from Alzheimer's disease
that he starts worrying
that he is experiencing cognitive
decline
so I think in the interest of time
let's
we're on 105 J
um I apologize just we don't have very
much time so I'm trying to figure out
what to focus on here
um
I think this most of this was covered by
Dr
eastvold
um
Could you actually go back to that last
one
the cognitive effect I didn't mean to to
cut to skip that obviously this is Dr
Fong's
um
uh cognitive FX is Dr Fung's Clinic is
that correct
yes that is
and uh
let's see
um how would you characterize what her
Clinic does so what they do is and this
is her words they do a boot camp to
rehabilitate people from mild traumatic
brain injuries whether it's weeks months
years or decades after the fact
and
um
what are the criticisms you have of
their approach and let's not talk about
the Imaging because that hasn't been
addressed
so the thing is what is offered There Is
Not Unusual in terms of Rehabilitation
for traumatic brain injuries
but moderate to severe traumatic brain
injuries none of these treatments have
really been established in mild
traumatic brain injury and that's fine
if they're using this for research to
try to establish that
um
the thing is is specifically in Mr
sanderson's Case
he was cognitively assessed over and
over again
at least once per day during the time he
was there they assess in the morning and
sometimes also in the afternoon give
them tasks of attention have them read
stuff see if they comprehend it see if
you know he has memory for it later that
day or the next day
every one of his cognitive assessments
at cognitive FX showed that he was
cognitively intact
let's move to this slide that talks
about a head injury do you recall Dr
Fong reporting that Mr Sanderson had
told her about a head injury he had
experienced uh because he was dehydrated
and fell down do you remember that so
yes but this didn't occur during his
intake for cognitive FX because it
happened afterwards I believe it was for
her deposition that it was mentioned
right
right and what was What's significant if
anything about that injury in your mind
so according to Mr Sanderson he arrived
home one day dehydrated passed out hit
his head and he believed he was
unconscious for at least 45 minutes and
then he awoke with a bump on his head as
he described
um
he thought this event could have killed
him and he couldn't believe that he
didn't call emergency services for it
now whether or not this is an
embellishment of what really happened or
not I don't know because he actually
didn't seek treatment for this event
but what I do know is by his own
description this is a much more
significant event than anything that
happened in 2016.
did you know whether he reported this
particular event to other providers
aside from Dr Fong no I did not see it
in my original review of va records
there's been some talk about Dr Mr
sanderson's
heart and heart conditions do you know
anything about his heart conditions
um I know a bit I know he has history of
heart palpitations
and um are those related to your
opinions in any way
it's not related to the opinions about
his medical condition but it's important
to know his sort of decision-making
strategies associated with it because
after Dr Goldstein recommended he either
try a psychostimulant for attention
problems or something for early onset or
early signs of dementia he chose to go
the psychostimulant route and he asked
to get on a medicine like Adderall or
Concerta
and both as cardiologists and
psychiatrists told him he should not
given his heart conditions
and he researched and he communicated
with him all the reasons why he thought
she'd be taking this and even the
specific medication he thought he should
or should not be taking
um and he eventually did go on the
medication assuming full risk because
both of his doctors had told him they
did not agree with that
so does that do those events tell you
anything about Mr sanderson's
post-accident symptoms the things he's
connected back to the accident
um I don't know if connected back to the
accident but again it shows sort of this
pattern of how he approaches his medical
conditions and how he deals with them
can be extreme at times I mean sometimes
he over reports it sometimes he denies
it we know before his accident
he delayed getting treatment for
potential cancer for years he got
referred over and over and over again to
have follow-up and he didn't because he
didn't want to deal with it
see and
you've talked about
the Dr Fong receiving a self-report from
Mr Sanderson uh
do you have any opinions about whether
Mr Sanderson is has a pattern of being
an unreliable
reporter of his own medical condition
so my concern is is he's reporting
symptoms to her
in a way that it made it sound like it
had continued through time but he had
complained once about gay difficulty he
was assessed and it was normal he had
complained about attention and memory
but it was tested and it was normal and
he wasn't providing the full picture of
these symptoms he was complaining about
and the time frame and the test results
associated with these complaints already
having been evaluated
let's go just because we got very little
time here this is your last slide I
believe your conclusions
and maybe we can just use this as a
moment to to sum up and make sure that
jury understands your opinion do you
believe that Mr Sanderson has any
permanent symptoms relating back to his
ski accident in 2016.
know by the end of July 2016 his records
from his treatment providers are quite
clean in that regard
and do you believe he had a concussion
questionable there's been a lot of
question regarding concussion I'm sorry
regarding loss of consciousness
regarding if there was real Amnesia it
was his disorientation just a brief what
happened or was it real disorientation
but I prefer giving it to him saying
that you know this event did cause a
mild concussion but we know almost
immediately there's no more symptoms of
it
all right maybe my last question
whether
you believe it's unprofessional for you
to render opinions about Mr Sanderson
having not met with him and evaluated
him personally okay
so anyone that engages in a
psychological evaluation for forensic
purposes meaning for legal purposes we
are Guided by the forensic psychology
specialty guidelines so where is the
American Psychological Association
oversees clinical work the forensic
psychology guidelines oversees legal
work and whether or not you're boarded
in forensic psychology you're supposed
to be abiding by those guidelines and
they very specifically talk about
knowing that sometimes it may not be
necessary to do an in-person evaluation
you may not have access to them I've had
cases where I've had to recreate mental
status for someone who's passed away and
changed their will at the end of their
life
sometimes you just don't have that
access and they are very specific in
saying that if there are any limitations
to your opinions
especially due to if you don't see them
in person that you identify those
um
but I felt very comfortable in giving
the opinions because I had all the
records from the time and for at least
five years afterwards
Dr Fong noted uh
that Mr Sanderson complained of
cognitive issues after the concussion
correct yes and
um
what is your response to her conclusions
about those cognitive assessments or
cognitive issues well in the records he
does complain about being foggy and
having trouble paying attention and
that's why he asked to get evaluated and
why he was sent to a speech therapist
for that evaluation in March in April
2016. so he was taken seriously at that
time with those complaints
but as we know that testing was clean
and even the speech therapist told him
that there's a big difference between
motivation and memory
do that executive function table that
that we showed Dr Fong or sorry Dr
eastfold yes and did you have anything
to add to what she said about it no I
think she was very thorough in
describing there's a big difference
between self-report and what is
objectively assessed
that's all the questions I have for now
thank you
Mr Egan
let's keep going
sure
all right
I noticed in your um
Fida
that's
at least there's a price I could tell
all of your experiences with criminal
cases
oh gosh no those were notable cases that
I've testified on about 75 to 80 percent
of my forensic work is civil
so uh with respect to
this case
you're telling the jury that um
I mean I mean you knew this was going to
be a big important case didn't you
yes all right
and did you ever request
to do a
personal evaluation
so we discussed this possibility because
I was originally asked to do a records
review
and I let them know that if after
reviewing the records I felt a need to
see him in person in order to render any
opinions regarding the questions that
were being asked that I would very
specifically request it isn't it
generally for someone like yourself a
professional independent professional
isn't it better to have a clinical
interview and do testing yourself
in a case like this when you're talking
about an incident that's more than five
years old no because the longer you get
away from an incident
the more distorted the memories get for
that incident
Okay so
a uh because at seven years old
you didn't think you needed to do an
evaluation and actually have a clinical
meeting with him
so I was actually concerned if he was
starting to develop dementia based on
his complaints
but again I'm seeing testing in 2020 and
even scans in 2021 Dr boam did a mental
status examination all of it showed
intact cognitive functioning so if I was
concerned that he had a newer onset
dementia or cognitive difficulties I
would have requested it
so um
no exam but no harm no fouls that's
basically it yes because we're
specifically talking about an acute
mild traumatic brain injury years ago
and the time after that
okay now
I think you're the only expert we had
from the defense
I do apologize this Cole has been
dogging me for a while
the only expert we had for the defense
that prepared an actual report
okay and it's about
come on
let's see here
without your Vita it's 54 pages single
spaced yes that's sort of like a
moderate range for me and sometimes
write reports well up to and over a
hundred Pages depending on how many
years of Records or other expert reports
that I might review I did a word search
and looked for the words executive
function
executive functions
the only reference I found to it
was where you're simply reporting a test
someone else gave is that a fair
statement yes because there's no report
in his medical records that he was
having executive functioning
difficulties
Port of Sam Goldston
yes I did did you read Alina Fong
well she didn't really do a report you
mean the pre and post like assessments
something I should know did you read a
report from her that's what I'm saying
I'm not sure what you're saying when you
say report because I don't believe she
wrote a report did you watch the
testimony of either Dr Fung or Dr
Goldstein uh yes I saw Dr Fox
did you see her testimony about
executive functioning it's one of the
main problems that Terry has that's the
main problems he self reports but again
every single assessment while he was
there showed he was intact there was
nothing in his actual medical records
documenting executive dysfunction other
than a self-report but if you come
to Utah to testify in a big case and you
know what's going to happen right
uh isn't it
from a professional standpoint
lacking in responsibility
not to address
his biggest problem
executive function you didn't even
mention it in the 54-page report that's
because in all the records I reviewed
that was not listed as his problem okay
did you read the depositions
of Carlene Davidson and uh
um not of his girlfriend
um but of the daughters he didn't read
his girlfriend's deposition no I did not
do you know that she was with him for
a year and a half before the ski crash
and six months after
that sounds like a long time beforehand
that doesn't sound quite right but I'll
take whatever you give me that's what
she testified to both in deposition and
in trial I don't know the specific
length of the relationship no
uh do you think a person a person like
that
might be able to tell you a lot about
executive functioning a lay person no I
trust the experts a lot more in that
regard okay so you don't look at before
and after Witnesses then
um if I had actually seen uh before and
after uh reports of anyone who knew him
I of course would have looked at that I
never saw that you didn't think
that her testimony by deposition
was important enough to read it did you
um it has nothing to do with important
or not I wasn't provided it and I
specifically asked for all the objective
data that there was including all the
medical records when you talk about
depositions of family members
you get into a very murky area because
they oftentimes have a vested interest
in the outcome
so the defense did not provide you
the deposition of of
Carlene Davidson
I wasn't provided any depositions until
last week after the trial actually
started the the defense didn't provide
you the deposition of
polygrason that's correct the fence
didn't provide you the deposition of
Shea Harris
yes that's correct
do you understand
that each of those three women two
daughters and a girlfriend longtime
girlfriend that was hoping to marry him
okay
said that there was a sudden and
dramatic
change in his condition beginning with a
ski crash are you aware of that yes as I
told you I didn't read them last week
and the main issue
covered from his slowness there's a lot
of contradictory things between the
depositions and the actual trial
um
okay but so I I did review them but
again you can't give the same weight to
a family self-report to symptoms when
you're talking about reviewing 20 years
of medical records that literally
documents objective information from
before to after okay it's a very short
question I answered and gave me a very
long answer let me try again okay I'm
just a simple country lawyer not very
smart okay but I can't read thank
goodness no
do you think
that the depositions of three people who
know him very well
could give you insight
on what his condition was before and
after the ski crash
I don't think it provides much objective
information but it provides personal
context
hey are you aware that Dr Fong
has treated thousands and thousands and
thousands
of people with traumatic brain injury
you'll wear that her businesses yes
okay are you aware that Dr Goldstein
it's written dozens of books and book
chapters
and authored many tests including one on
Executive function are you aware of that
yes but I don't refer to that as a test
when it's a self-report it's referred to
as a scale and that's how he refers to
it good are you aware he developed that
yes I am are you aware that he testified
here in open court that I shouldn't use
worldwide
uh no I'm not I did not see his
testimony are you aware that Dr Fong
treats about 20 I think of her patients
or come from other countries
no I don't know that you know she was
last week she was in Holland Netherlands
came in a lecture
on what she does are you aware of that
no okay let me ask you if you made an
effort
to
tell the whole story in your report
I tried to tell this story as completely
as I could as you said my first report
was 56 pages long that was a summary of
all the materials I'd been given at that
time
section of her
any objection uh jacked us to hearsay
there's an objection as to hear say that
be sustained
all right the report is here say
yeah
can we admit it
sure so sure
on something she wrote for this jury
sure you can do that but you can do that
without showing it to her
fairness knowing it to the jury anyway
reports are never admissible we have a
bunch we could admit to but I think it
would bore the jury to read them so go
ahead and ask your question
did
you have your report handy
yes
let's take a look at it page 23.
now you know and I can show her uh an
admitted exist right sure
for the record which exhibit are you
making uh this is 28 that's the 27.
plaintiff's 27 okay it is
let's take a look here
now
I'm going to take my trusty red pencil
hit by Pentax
uh and I'm going to put a little bracket
out here
so I can follow along now
uh this is by the way
evaluation done
June 1 2017. okay
all right
now on your report
page 23
did you say the following
although he did not mean I'm sorry could
you show me page 23 okay where second
paragraph done okay thank you although
he did not meet the full criteria for
major depressive disorder
he did not have some features and
symptoms of depression
it was noted he open quote
does not meet criteria for any type of
cognitive impairment
period close quote is that what you
wrote yes okay let's look at the exact
the actual record yes
just inserted the word not in the first
sentence excuse me
after the first it was noted he does not
meet criteria that one
you said he did not have some features
and symptoms of depression
okay I'm sorry he
let me let me start over thanks for
catching that
although he did not
all the markings are yours Bob is that
right yes
although he did not meet full criteria
for major depressive disorder he did
have some features and symptoms of
depression
okay
it was noted he open quote does not meet
criteria
any type of cognitive impairment period
of close quote yes correct is that what
you wrote yes and then the next sentence
says uh
buprofen was increased to 300 milligrams
a day so that's the next sentence right
um yes all right however
the actual record you were quoting from
says
uh
uh what you what you wrote is she does
not meet criteria for any type of
cognitive impairment at this time
there's a comma there
however as patient clearly as patient
clearly a high functioning individual I
think is is missing at Baseline this may
be masking
compensating for any deficits
now you left that out didn't you
well yes that portion doesn't make any
sense to me I just said did you leave
that out yes I don't write word for word
everything in the record in my report
and the language that you left out
however as patient is clearly a I think
means his high function individual at
Baseline
this may be masking compensating for any
deficits that language that you left out
potentially that language says does it
not
that the fact that he is a high Baseline
high functioning individual
is going to mask his cognitive deficits
and you left that out didn't you
yes because that didn't make sense to me
and I can explain that
no further questions
thank you
so my first question will be uh
will you explain that okay
so first of all
you can't what we say in neuropsychology
you can't fake good unless someone's
given you the test and you're cheating
you can't perform higher than you can on
any sort of test and when he was tested
by Dr Madsen he was performing at a high
level of abilities average to above
average functioning that's exactly what
you would expect with someone who is a b
student all their lives went optometry
school was basically a high functioning
High average person their entire life
his testing was a hundred percent
consistent with his test results so I
didn't understand what it would mean
that he could be masking deficits
because he wasn't
showing deficits and you can't fake good
do you watch any testimony of Mr
sanderson's daughters during this trial
yes I did and did watching their
testimony change any of your opinions
um
not from a clinical sense
I'm not going to address any of the
family issues
but it's clear that the daughters who
testified in court were not very
knowledgeable about their father's
mental health history
I'm gonna just put up on the screen here
again
I believe this is your last
slide 105 V and ask you
whether any questioning from plaintiff's
council has changed your opinion that Mr
Sanderson has no permanent psychological
or cognitive issues due to the February
26 2016 incident
and he has never tested as being
cognitively impaired
in his brief emotional activation
emotional exacerbation abated as of July
2016. my opinion Remains the Same that's
all thank you thank you Mr Sykes
no questions all right you may step down
thank you
we will take our final recess
[Music]
short recess yes I do want before the
jury comes in I wanted to talk about
remaining and I can do that now or in
five minutes
why don't we do it in five minutes to
give me a chance to look what we have
thank you how about 10 minutes so we can
let's do it let's come back in five and
then the jury will come back in 10.
thank you
foreign
may be seated
judge might be possible to uh let us
take our coats off again I mean sure I'm
the only one but yes yes you may so did
you get the print out here
okay so if we assume that there's three
hours and 45 minutes of jury time left
that's an out that's 2 45 for tomorrow
and one
assume that then by my computation the
plaintiff gets two hours and 23 minutes
include which includes your closing
and the defendant gets 121. did we agree
on one hour for closings
I need an hour and 10.
so one hour and then plus 10 minutes so
one 110 for defendants as well
no one hour for dependence your honor I
think some of these delays on
evidentiary matters which were overruled
should be attributable to the planner
for not to us you took one matter under
advisement
we're being we're working as hard as we
can well there was there were 14 minutes
of delays with the last witness that
I'll charge to the plaintiff whoa can I
add that to my time then 35 135
we may have to ask the jury to come
early then tomorrow in order to make in
order to stay on that schedule but and
can I tell you what I envision your
honor
shouldn't be
I thought they were already calculated
in the numbers no okay so it's so it's a
total so the defendant has 135 and the
defendant has 223 remaining thank you
your honor and I intend to use 30
minutes now
and uh reserve 105. the one hour is for
our closing the five minutes is for
uh if they're calling a rebuttal witness
tomorrow morning we do intend to rest
today
I would like to know if they're calling
a rebuttal witness tomorrow
yes we are 9 A.M is it is
also is it one witness
Maybe Who
well let's not play games
tomorrow morning there's for sure one
witness all right how who is it how so
you're dividing your closing uh between
the two of you liability
damages I'm gonna take 45 minutes and Mr
Egan's gonna take 15 minutes okay and
have you decided how you're going to
split your closings I'm not yet
Mr uh Mueller will be involved okay
probably 10 to 15. and I don't have any
problem with going an hour on their on
their main argument and then 10 minutes
for rebuttal do you
so the reason I want to know what their
rebuttal plan is for tomorrow morning so
that I can decide how long to take but
this very Witness
and so this idea one maybe two one look
why don't we get the jury in here and
then we can have this conversation at
the end after that
well it's about if do I take 30 or 35
minutes with them right now that's why I
want to know
so we really only have probably another
45 minutes of trial today right
because there's not another witness if
you rest
that's true I want to make sure our
exhibits are in I also have a
Court TV objection to make your honor
well why don't we deal with that at the
end of the day unless it needs to be
done right now
all right
we've had two decorum order violations
I'm reporting a third right now uh
media I've yes no wait the two previous
ones by that Media or by the AP reporter
uh sometimes it's hard for me to tell
your honor if it's a still photographer
it's not Court TV no
uh my my client I've had this on two
reports two individual reports
there is a direct camera on my client's
face
in the last uh
for the last bit of testimony I wasn't
speaking
and it was just focused on her direct
violation of how the court has
interpreted the decorum order
do you have a picture of that reports of
close-ups of Gwyneth Paltrow on court TV
today
uh
when she's not speaking and I'm not
speaking
do we have
of that
try to get them would you
well let okay so that's noted and I'm
going to ask Court TV to to if they need
any clarification on the decorum order
to ask for it but otherwise they should
only be going on the lectern and on the
witness
unless an objection is made at Council
table and then they can show Council
table
thank you judge we've had
been
contractions about the decorum order I
think you ought to charge all of that to
them
we've had not one
on our side
and um
Mr Builder is very famous and so I think
that you know
my cousin's Ferris so I'm serious
there's been a lot of these that decorum
things and and none of them have been
charged to eat in either side because
they have been out of the hearing of the
jury that we've dealt with those issues
so it's you're being charged for jury
time okay
um
so we'll take the last witness right now
and you're going to take about 30
minutes correct is that right yes and
then then we'll
your honor I don't expect taking 30
minutes on our side but what I'd like to
do is I mean obviously I don't want to
be charged with that because we need to
use that for tomorrow morning but we can
use time for defense to enter in their
exhibits all of the Motions outside of
the jury Etc
okay well let's get the jury in I know
and then we'll deal with whatever issues
that we have can I predict one more
thing we're going to start uh showing
exhibits
from exhibit defense exhibit once you
get the jury lined up
defense exhibit 111 starting at page 47.
uh I don't want objections on Foundation
of these I went through every single one
of them on his deposition he recognized
it he didn't dispute the date
and if I'm being charged
for times I don't want objections as to
Foundation on any of those documents
page 47 correct and going on for about
30 pictures there's about 162 pages in
the exhibit 111. I'm gonna stop I'm
gonna stop at 87. so 47 to 87. so those
40 pages any objection to receiving
those
one through eighty what was it 47 to 87.
I mean yeah and this was the subject of
emotion in Lemony I believe yes
and I indicated that if there if there
were objections that were made that were
valid then they then they're valid but
if they're not valid they'd be charged
the time would be charged to the
objecting party
as long as we know that many of these
Council
ascribe these documents to being
produced by my client and they're
obviously not because he's in the photo
my question is just is do you have any
objection to the court receiving them as
an exhibit no your honored okay so
defense exhibit 111 Pages 47 through 87
are received
anything else before the jury walks in
oh thank you
okay
seated
Mr Owens you may proceed
Mr Sanderson you'll need to be sworn
do you swear that the testimony you are
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God
good afternoon sir
okay
uh Mr Sanderson we've met before we we
didn't finish so we're trying to work
our way in I'm on a 30 minute clock so
I'm gonna try to ask questions uh very
directly and just have you say yes or no
if I can I will
did you
upon filing your lawsuit
in a press conference compare my client
to King Kong coming out of the Jungle
yes or no that was not my intention did
you do that did I make up those words or
those your words to The Press I'm not
sure but probably sounds familiar do you
dispute it
I dispute my intentions that's all I
King Kong coming out of the jungle
pardon press conference I was pretty
did you say those words about my client
I meant to say King Kong just chased
someone out of the jungle
that's what I meant did you refer to her
as Godzilla to your daughter I did not I
don't remember that she testified to
that I don't remember that and it's gone
sorry
you told everyone it was a hit and run
right
wrote to your own Hometown newspaper and
said
she hit and ran me
I did say that and that's been dismissed
by this court do you understand that
um
yes I guess so yes
yes I want to talk uh please bring that
up this is a d110
and do you see it on your screen sir
can you maybe enlarge the first half
post-incident travel by Dr Sanderson Mr
Sanderson
did you go to Peru yes after the
Collision all of these are after the
Collision okay yes is it Machu Picchu
Costa Rica yes Walk The Golden Trail
yes Machu Picchu is in Peru
uh yes floated down the Amazon
uh yes I guess so Costa Rica did you do
a zip line
shame trip yes did you go to Europe
visit Netherlands Germany Switzerland
Italy France Belgium
with my daughter Jenny yes bottom half
James please did you go to the
Netherlands three times
I don't remember well if you're
disputing it then we pull it out of your
out of your deposition I don't remember
I have no region disputed or agree
Morocco twice
true
uh likely very likely Canary Islands I
need to know if you're disputing these
things I can't dispute it no Thailand
did you go to Thailand after the
Collision
yes did you visit at least the states of
Washington Oregon Montana and Idaho
after the Collision
probably yes
47.
you're a face Booker right at least when
you were at the time you post a lot on
social media
relative to other people didn't seem
like I did very little all of these
pictures are from your your personal
Facebook after the Collision okay
let's go to number 47.
and is there a way to enlarge it James
is this you uh doing a selfie in your
backyard beautiful sunset probably so
page 48
having a party in your backyard no
that was somebody else's party I just
dropped it was my renter's party if you
can straighten it up Cinco de Mayo
and she wanted to use the back deck and
enlarge if you can you went to a party
in your backyard registered the
Collision true I just visited to make
sure they had everything I needed yes
yes
page 49 not very good quality
uh
this is from you and your girlfriend at
the time smiling true yes yes next one
forty number five zero this is a picture
of you and your girlfriend yes and uh
smiling big right smile camera yep next
one 51 this is you and your girlfriend
is that southern Utah hiking
I don't remember where looks like you
have one of those cool backpacks with
water uh on is that true yes that's true
next one 52 this is you going on a hike
taking a picture of a moose right yes
nothing like fresh cool air a Running
Brook and easily entertained and hungry
company
that's your your personal post is that
true yes
53. this is another picture of you on a
hike true
yes trying out my camera saying smile
every one of these pictures is after the
Collision page 54
this is you
've got another pitcher you and your
girlfriend on a hike smiling true yes
you have that cool backpack on again yes
Camelback is that the brand it is page
57 let's go again is this you same year
of the accident hiking
yes it looks pretty steep trying to get
back in shape again page 58 is this you
kayaking after the Collision just
now this is we're seven months after the
Collision absolutely not that is that a
kayak above you I don't know what it is
sir I asked you about this in your
deposition is this you kayaking no
absolutely not oh boy
I was trying on helmets to protect my
head did you go kayaking after the
Collision
I don't remember that but this is not it
this was in a local it's a whole
different question Let's ignore the
picture thank you did you kayak after
the Collision
no I don't think so
all right let's try to find it
you went scuba diving right
uh what year after I don't even care
what year after the Collision I did go
sometime after yeah
you went to an auto show in Germany does
this sound right with my daughter yes
went to a shooting range does this sound
right yes BMX bike show
right
um
maybe not sure scuba diving four
different occasions is that true uh
probably on the same week on the same
trip probably went on a boat ride of
several canals in the Netherlands true
yes you rode bikes yes did bus tours
yes boat tours
uh yes Auto Show we talked about
explored older towns in Central Europe
true true with my daughter it was
wonderful Morocco
is that is there a word called
m-a-r-r-a-k-e-c-h
yes what is that again it's a city all
right you visited there twice I did
explore Jewish markets there yes
cultural sites Dion the Dior Museum
is that cool yes I did
[Music]
all right let's move on the kayak is
there a reason you're
are you wearing a helmet for a kayak
with a kayak right above you
you know I mean a I'm in a sporting
goods store on the west side that has
everything in it and there was a mirror
right there
um and I was trying on helmets for
protection not for kayaks just for
General protection
maybe maybe for skiing at that time I
was looking they didn't have anything I
wanted all right I was looking for a
mips helmet let's go to 59
he went to a rock concert is that true
after the Collision I probably did same
year let's go to 60.
I think this is when I tried the green
working for the Green Team recycling
again that's after the Collision yes
that's the team I tried it that's you on
the first uh row on the right with the
big smile through yes that's me let's go
to 61. oh and Carlene's here
61. is this your girlfriend at the time
in a cool looking waterfall it is let's
go to 62
is this you after the Collision
uh up in the ski resorts or what is this
about a year later
um I think I was just walking up in the
hills above my house okay page 63
is this you skiing after the Collision
um it could be I did go with Robin one
time to try it out I tried it by myself
twice okay 60 well I I'm asserting
that this is you skiing after the
Collision do you dispute it it was that
following year
I don't dispute it okay 64.
is this how are you out with your
drinking buddies
yes uh did you and did you have an
installed breathalyzer in your car
yes or no
um I had a personal one that you just
hold in your hand page 65 is this you
and your notes
I'm
is this you and your
yes being proud of my daughters being
strong daughters because we're at an
exhibit that was about strong women page
66 and you went to that exhibit right I
did
is this you this is a post
highly recommending the the escape room
for fun family engagement and problem
solving yes especially if you go with
teenagers it's a ball
okay but you're you're actually
contributing to figuring out how to get
out of a
kind of a scary Mysterious Room you just
put the kids in charge they figured out
it's amazing 67.
is this you wheels up at Salt Lake Bound
for Europe
the year after the Collision that's the
empty seat next to me that Robin was
supposed to sit in and told me she
didn't like me anymore that my
personality changed did you go to Europe
and did you post this wheels up Bound
for Europe I posted it it doesn't say
I'm really sad that my girlfriend won't
come with me it doesn't say that it's
like nope okay page six wasn't sure that
would happen 68 Switzerland lots of
wondrous sites
in my travels through Europe right yes
my daughter took Robin's Place 69. the
Frankfurt International Auto Show year
after the Collision
Mercedes exhibit page 70.
another beautiful day in paradise with
your girlfriend is this your post after
the Collision feeling happy it says at
the very top
did you post this
I believe I did 71.
you're on some kind of tour boat in the
Netherlands or something does this sound
right I don't remember where but yes
page 72
is this you and your girlfriend uh
in the Netherlands that was a new friend
yes page 73 is this you
uh
on a bike ride looking fit and happy
yes yes page 74.
is this you at the Siam park with some
friends
um just the two Jessica and her son
Shaquille and what what country is Siam
Park in
I think it's Canary Islands it's just
off Bronco page 75 you and your buddies
uh
one night it's my turn to be wingman
there's no chicks and dancing girls do
you see that that's your post I do page
is this you uh
doing yoga or mamba or what it's Zumba
and she let me bring my two
granddaughters there and we had a blast
she's really good it's page 77.
crazy fun
at the Pioneer School
did you post that I did is that you in
the green hat yes you were sort of the
centerpiece the spotlight person in the
play
yes I played Zero the Hero for my
kindergarten it's cool you did that page
78 is this one of the other pictures you
posted from that event
looks like it and you're the centerpiece
of the whole thing right you're the star
yeah I loved having those little kids
sitting on my lap and thinking I was a
hero age 79 is this you golfing
um after the event actually just showing
Shaquille how to hit balls I don't I
don't remember golfing I think I just
took him in driving range right yes
80. is this you
are you in this River Cruise River boat
I believe so okay
um yeah page 81
someone you were with or you go Parish
sailing
this was in Switzerland no I didn't
compare saying so this is just a
stranger in Switzerland yes okay 82
is this you and your girlfriend
um my daughter Polly Polly thank you for
telling me that I hope she was not
offended by my question is this
something you posted
I don't know she probably posted it I
believe 83
is this you on a camel it is
what's what country is Morocco because
Ikea had Bronco Heritage let's go to 84.
is that you in front of something cool
yes one of millions of temples in
Thailand that I kept telling my friends
I got to travel so
page 85
is that you it is yes poster boy for
Fitness at age 75. would you agree
not at all page 86 is this you doing
miniature golf
yes
page 87 is this you and your girlfriend
on Facebook no that's my daughter Polly
again she looks just like me I think
except 1500 years younger yeah sorry
Paulie if you're listening
all right let me just
um
I have more pictures
let's go to 99z defendants
99z uh right those I don't think those
have been admitted yet move to admit uh
which ones 99 Z
through as many as I can get through in
the next five to seven minutes
some water sure
could you bring some water for the
witness this on the desk oh
I'm told I have 10 minutes
so we're gonna go through some more
pictures
move to admit 99z
through 99 GGG
go ahead
99z through GTG is received
several of those so perhaps I'll go
address something else
did you say
when you said decided that you had been
hit from behind that you felt like you
were flying
I didn't know how else to describe it it
was yes I was weightless yes
you told me about three near-death
experiences after the Collision
true I did yes one was where you knocked
yourself out and you were out a long
time because
the whatever had melted
had actually warped the wood floor do
you remember this I did yes
did you seek medical care for that
no
wasn't tuned in did you think you were
out at least 45 minutes at the time I
did but now I've come to conclusion that
I it was 2 30 in the morning and I just
wiped up all the water on the floor and
I didn't get it all I think that's what
caused the swelling it usually takes
about 45 minutes so I'm pretty sure that
would be impossible to be on did you
think it was important for you to maybe
go see a doctor and having hit your head
and being out for a long period enough
that the water warped the wood floor at
the time I thought that but I was not
making good decisions in that sort of
near-death experience happened twice
again another near-death experience was
you were cutting a cardboard box and and
cut your leg is that true with the box
cutter yes through the femoral artery
looked like a murder scene
and then a third near-death experience
was an accidental overdose of
medications yes and they had to give you
Narcan because you'd take an oxycontin
and tramadol is that right I didn't know
I taken Tramadol I took just to an art I
took just the Oxycontin that I had for
my ribs actually my ribs are being
broken from the ski accident and you
blame Miss Paltrow Miss Paltrow for all
three of those near-death experiences
after true I don't know if I should be
claiming it right now in this lawsuit
yes very unusual for me not to make good
decisions medical decisions
I think I'll reserve my remaining time
for uh reader redirect
thank you
yes thank you
so you need a drink
all right
Terry you've been shown lots of pictures
about all the different travels that
you've done
have you always traveled in your life I
have well
you traveled before yes
yes traveled after the accident oh yes
have you ever told this jury or tried to
insinuate in this trial that you
couldn't travel
why did you travel
after after the ski accident why did you
travel
cognitive therapist
back to your routine assuming you can do
that the better you'll be and that's
been proven some research
now all these pictures they look really
great I mean you're smiling you're happy
um reflect
did you struggle on those trips
yes I I really did I I couldn't go by
myself anymore and I found that out the
hard way when Robin decided that she
didn't like me anymore after five years
I asked my daughter to go along and she
didn't get there until the next morning
bought her a flight and and she came
over and what did I do stepped off the
curb now which daughter was that Jenny B
that's Jenny that's the Jenny that we've
heard all about that said all kinds of
nasty things about you she went on a
trip to Europe with you
and we had a great time yes
yes she loved it you were shown some
pictures of the Green Team and
volunteering
you talked a little bit about that last
week but what has this accident done to
you with volunteering
uh dozens of different volunteer groups
I worked with probably 200 a year
volunteer easily and green team was a
big one I'd go up and pick up aluminum
plastic hard work bending stooping
lifting sixteen thousand steps and you
get everything done by one o'clock in
the morning go home and my plan was to
do that
but I got lost
and it took me a long time to figure out
how to get home I refused to use my maps
I just I just don't need it but that was
that was the first real time that I
thought oh my I something is really
different it's I have no instincts for
North anymore like I used to and you've
heard you've been here now all this week
um you've heard all kinds of doctors
talking about how you were getting old
how you were worried about dementia all
of these mental issues this is just a
natural progression of
of how you were
the juries heard from family and friends
that
witnessed how you changed
I'm just setting the background I'm
going to ask the question right now okay
okay hear it what is your perception
Terry how you changed was it dramatic
was it slow what changes did you see and
did you perceive following this ski
Collision
looking back on that time I was
determined to
prove everything I did was to stamp that
in my record that this guy is trying
hard he does not want to bring that into
his life it was a big deal
and
I just found that it was like flipping a
switch it was like I looked back and it
was the bright side and now I'm in the
dark side
and my volunteering stop so a lot of my
self-esteem stopped I couldn't do it I
couldn't do the job in fact I got chewed
out by somebody I knew for 30 years
saying
not that long 15 years saying Terrace
excited utterance sorry honey and it's
not offered for the the truth
you may answer for a limit it'll be
accepted for a limited purpose
I can answer yes
yeah I I yeah I I kept I getting chewed
out because I couldn't remember what I
was doing even though I had done it for
so many years and I'll try that again a
second time maybe two years later and
out again by a lady I'd known for quite
a while
something's different about me
so how did that make you feel
oh I I it's always nice and you know
that if you walk into a room and it says
hey come on over here it's Terry you
know but
when they just say oh it's Terry
there's something different there's
people
don't see me the same way and I don't
feel the same and it's very
disappointing to short answer very
discouraging
you were asked about the the press
conference and um referring to miss
Paltrow as King Kong
were you referring to her as King Kong
or the noise that you heard
what what did King Kong refer to
oh withdraw I'll withdraw overruled go
ahead
my apologies to Ms Paltrow because my
intention was got twisted up in my
intentions and and was to say it was
sounded like a lady getting chased by
King Kong out of the Jungle it was that
kind of a I'm
restarted and I want you to describe
that okay because you kind of whispered
it a little bit last week
when did you hear a scream
as I passed those big signs that said
slow down seriously I just went into a
Glide I just started gliding I was going
plenty slow not passing anybody on my
left I just started gliding and then the
silence was broken of that
just simply gliding down the hill not
making turns
and always on the right side and the
sinus was broken with a hysterical
screen the very best hysterical scream
you've ever heard at what point did the
scream happen was it before you were hit
when you were hit as you're going down
when was it
I heard it and tensed up at right
absolutely a half a second probably
before I got hit in fact I'm not so sure
the scream even ended
when I got hit it's it ended
as I as she hit me and then over we went
okay
so
there's there was some testimony uh from
Miss Paltrow again that
she was hit in the back by a very large
man or that there was a very large man
could you just step down for just a
moment
step off the stand for just a moment
what does that mean that I'm going to
ask a question from the question
inserting evidence into the record
overruled the jury will remember what
the evidence was
a very large man
many times I wish I was but
there's a reason I asked Miss Paltrow
why she was 510 or how tall she was last
week
commentary let's have questions Miss
Paltrow testified she was fight
overruled it's just Preparatory go ahead
Miss Paltrow testified she was a 510
last week how tall are you Terry five
foot five thank you
the accident that day
the ski accident that day
were there a lot of people on the Run
was it crowded or was it deserted
most runs that I've seen it was compared
to most runs it was very crowded I would
say
moderately Too High full is what it
seemed like lots of people
and were you skiing back and forth on
the run or did you stick to the right
side that's
the fact that's been changed
right side exactly like I said
saw all the people con congealed in the
middle and just went diagonal straight
over to the right side and stayed inside
of that five-yard boundary where nobody
was
one lone person coming out once in a
while that I was wary of that was down a
ways
and that's when the scream happened and
that's when you were hit absolutely
how did you land
to your recollection
Hill of course I'm going downhill so our
heads are downhill so that's I just I
saw down the hill and crashed there and
I didn't remember doing this but I did
put my hands out to catch myself that
was instinctual saved my face but um we
landed and I remember lurching off the
right foot as I got hit I thought I got
to use whatever I can and I pushed
deliberately a little bit to the right
because I did not want anyone in the
crowd to get tangled up in us as they're
going by and I did see just before I hit
the ground I just remember seeing a
skier on the left goodbye
Mr Owens asked you
hit and run you said it was a hit and
run why did you say it was a hit and run
I was considered I couldn't run with
something when
you ran into something or somebody and
then you just left the scene and as far
as I'm concerned there was no one there
when I woke up no one except a angry man
as I said and then I saw Craig and is
that how you felt that I was yes that
was like if you get knocked down and
knocked out and nobody's around
afterwards that did it that's
thank you for clarifying you've been
here for a number of days you've heard
all the doctors testify your entire life
has now been broadcast to the world
I feel like I've been fleshed out and
anyone up here I think would feel the
same way and very painful in fact I
think you just me back there well I
could never go on another dating site
again
it's true
everyone knows
too much do you regret bringing this
lawsuit
well that's the purpose I think is to
make me regret this lawsuit and uh
that it's the pain of trying to sue a
celebrity
it's just very difficult I will tell
everyone that you're going to get
exposed
we're not talking about this case now
he's talking about
the world
sustained as to the generalization was
it important to you to bring this law
it was I felt like
I was seriously injured
and then I had so many insults add to
that I think as I said the other day so
many insults added to that and layered
on that after a while post Collision
conduct is not an issue layered on
insults is not part of a lawsuit
overruled
I I'm classifying as an insult that is
absolutely ignoring me ignorance and and
that's what it felt like it's like what
is going on here this is obviously an
issue that someone needs to be
accountable for and if they're never
accountable what are they going to do
they're going to do it again now we have
the
molesting of young children on an island
denial is a ridiculous testimony he's
talking about pained as to relevance the
last part the Jewish industry guard
that's all I have Terry
nice
do you realize
you are the reason your life has been
exposed to the world you not miss Potter
I'm realizing that now yes
do you remember
you've said you shrunk and lost weight
since the incident right
well I gained I ballooned
now when we stand you up you've you've
lost like 15 pounds and shrunk three
inches right I have yes or no I had no
idea I guess yes I was just a few days
ago you said I was 175 to 80 and 5 8.
remember I said that not here oh you
know what
In This Very trial overruled I know why
I said that it's because the VA records
weighs you with all your clothes and
everything on and I knew that's what you
were reading give you three inches you
with me heels do did you have heels on
the top all right
you even called yourself pudgy at the
time that you were pudgy do you remember
that word what time are you using the
pudgy what time frame the time when I
deposed you
you said you were pudgy okay that's kind
of a fun turn yeah do you dispute it I
don't what does that word mean
um I never thought about it just sort of
gotten a little more roundish I guess
haven't defined that before did you did
I hear you say I you didn't like to be
ignored don't ignore me are those the
words you used
just just now just two minutes ago I
probably did say that
let's go to page 170 of your deposition
and ask that it be published and brought
up
do you have your transcript right there
can you can you link us what this is
your honor may I do that
uh it hasn't worked in the past and uh
so I'm under 32 you can use the
deposition you can certainly read it
into the record but we don't need to all
right let's go to page 170 D and I'll
assist you if you want me to I don't
even know where one seven I don't see I
see
her oh it's another whole other can I
close the exhibits
the the three piles of paper there one
of those
I said if you'd want to get him to the
page that would be great yes thank you
that's what I want to do
I wouldn't have known which ones to look
at
it
we're starting okay
and do you see I'm going to start
reading at line 12.
because of the good stuff
this lady is on my left
well let's go back for a little remember
I said I want to know what's going on in
the 10 seconds before the impact do you
remember
I do remember that but is it written
here I don't know
yes that's my question on page 169 and
then on 170
you said and then I remember there's
this lady on my left that was kind of
tentative
so I deliberately in fact I think I said
passing on your right pretty sure I did
I usually do passing on your right and
then you know it was just easy it was
just as easy smooth Glide and there were
not a whole lot of people
and I'm I'm not I don't want to be
interrupted right now please page 170
and when I got to that point I could see
the bottom of the hill I could see that
the trees came in a little bit from the
right it seems like and then the whole
slope was opened up
there were a few occasional people out
there but I could see all the way to the
bottom
there were nobody nobody
and then this and nobody could have
passed on my left except the gal I had
just passed so that gal I was really
conscious of because I still worried
about her and so as I went past her I
went inches inches per second pasture I
just remember it took forever to me for
me to get past her and there were skis
and when they disappeared out of my
vision that's that's the time I heard
this
so that's the time I heard this saw
indicating scream and then bang it
happened it was about a second and a
half and it just hit me right in the
back
all right so do you recall that in the
seconds before the Collision
you were trying you were worried about
the person to your left do you recall
that I
gave her plenty of space because she
seemed like I moved way to the right
before the off-peached yes but you were
with inches of her
no I was not with an inches for her all
right what did you say here
well first of all did I correctly read
your testimony
oh yes
all right
it took
you were inches per second past her
I just remember it took forever to get
past her and there were skis now you're
you're right eye
has problems right a little bit yeah not
a little bit yes a little bit blind no
you told three of your providers at the
VA I'm blind in my right eye I use the
word Loosely you used it and you're an
optometrist right I did all right so
let's not say a little bit because
that's pretty different from blind all
right so you're you're trying to not hit
this person on the left
and you're blind in your right eye
do you agree that you've turned
to clear the person on your left now I
knew I had plenty of room before I
started by her I would have gone by her
without knowing I had plenty you took
great care didn't you to make sure you
didn't hit
the beginner skier on the left which you
just don't is that true yes
that's all thank you
Mr van Orman
cautiously
I've had a long time to think about
whether I want to be dangerous or
cautious and I choose cautious yes I
don't take chances
what is your vision like in your right
eye my vision I will I will compare it
to a flat light day
I have flat light days if anybody knows
what that means it seems you you just
can't tell the Contours as well
of of where you're at I'm sure you have
to be a little more careful make sure
you get in the right spot at the right
time so I get a lot of practice skiing
flight line days that's what it amounts
to I think it's how I describe it any
trouble skiing with your right eye
never any trouble I and unrestricted
skiing they don't handicap me on the ski
slope or driver's license I'm unlimited
I
do fine that's all I have thank you how
more questions remember okay thank you
Mr Sanderson thank you
any more witnesses Mr Owens I know your
honor okay
given our court limitations on time uh
the defense rests we reserve the right
maybe as soon as the jury's gone to
admit into evidence each of our exhibits
okay as long as we have a good
understanding of our ability to do that
um
so we'll reserve your your formal
resting until after we deal with the
exhibits thank you members of the jury
were going to recess now until nine
o'clock tomorrow morning you're probably
wondering what's going to happen next
and so now the defense will be resting
today the plaintiff has indicated that
they may have a short amount of
testimony to put on tomorrow morning and
then right after that we will do the
jury instructions and then the attorneys
will have an opportunity to sum the
evidence up for you expecting that that
should all be done in the morning
tomorrow and start deliberations after
that it may bleed into the afternoon
depending on how things go
you never can tell these things exactly
but that's that's what we're shooting
for so have a good evening remember
still following my admonition not to try
to learn anything about the case not to
do any of your own investigation and
avoid any press reports about this and
please don't discuss the case with
anyone if they try to discuss it with
you just tell them you can't the judges
ordered you
not to so thank you
I agree
so do you have your exhibits lined up
for entry right now
the easiest thing to do might be
to stand in front of you with the
official one that's going to go to the
jury
because there are a lot of different
things floating around if you want we
can do that so you're we don't take your
Honors time
um
I think we can do it in 10 minutes but I
I don't think
I think between the lawyers
and and your clerk I don't think we
necessarily need you to do it because I
think we'll come to a stipulation okay
um
well I'll be here for at least another
hour so if anything pops up or whenever
you're ready for me you can just message
me and I'll come out and we can enter
the exhibits
and I I put on your tables earlier today
what I believe may be the final jury
instructions but we can talk about those
in the morning
maybe 8 15 tomorrow morning
your honor may I have a suggestion as
well I think maybe everybody can kind of
work together get all their exhibits in
whatnot maybe at 8 15 the defense can
rest and then we would like just a few
minutes to make some motions right uh so
if we're all here at 8 15 that'd be a
great time to do that okay why don't we
do that and so I as I mentioned Miss Van
Norman I put jury instructions on both
tables a couple of copies so I'd like to
get your take on whether those look
final to you and then what we don't have
is a final verdict form
and I don't know I wanted to get your
take on it do you want to go with a
special verdict form do you want to each
present your own verdict forms for your
side of the case do you want to have a
general verdict with special
interrogatories how do you want to
approach
I I don't I don't see where the parties
have talked much about the special or
the form of the verdict
we've talked uh we're only off by I
think two questions okay I think
um
I wouldn't I would love a copy of what
your honor has I don't have anything I
have what you have
and then beyond that I I usually start
with the Muji during or the Muji one
that's on the website right the counter
claim I guess one issue on this special
verdict form for instance is are can we
fill in just one dollar instead of you
must find damages that's one of the
issues I think that makes sense
uh your honor they can do that in their
closing argument yeah but just to avoid
an error of some kind and an argument
and objections if they do something
different why not have why not fill it
in if it's a stipulated amount of damage
well there's this okay we're just
inviting error otherwise I I think
that's appropriate and then it would
just be a yes or no on that right your
honor spoiliation we sent in a just
three hours ago a proposed spoiliation
one we reworded it Peter I should say
Peter and give him credit you guys have
that reword you haven't had a chance to
look at it it's three hours did they get
it Peter
could we handle that briefly tomorrow
yeah absolutely and um
okay so special verdict form
I don't know that we can do more and
uh and you come up with what you like
best
and then give it to us and then we talk
I'm looking for the parties to provide
me with this with whatever form you want
the verdict to be in we'd like the Emoji
one I think
but your your verdict form first of all
it didn't track
if you look at the bottom or if you look
just after the first part of the verdict
Forum where it talks about Terry
sanderson's two or I'm sorry two
questions about Gwyneth Paltrow the
instructions don't track and then the
other thing is it has nothing about the
counter claim
and I'm not sure how you know you've got
okay so we're dealing with comparative
fault
um and and it's not really clear how
that's going to work with the counter
claim on your form
I think it's close I mean I prefer the
language that you guys have because
that's what's from the website form
um I unders you know I'm willing to use
other language if you want to but
I guess I'm looking for I'm looking to
you to put together the verdict form
yeah we prefer that defense counsel may
have other ideas
I think he's looking
yeah we'll talk we'll cooperate we'll
cooperate with them right okay yeah and
then we can we can address it tomorrow
when we appear at uh 8 15. after the
motions
anyone who wants to argue
be here
or object I'm just a country boy
you like that
and he's just a simple country lawyer
did we just say that at the same time so
your honor we did file both parties I
want to make sure you have what both
parties submitted do you pre-trial for
the verdict form yes I do okay you have
that yes
um
I'm going to be working on closing so I
almost
is this a burden to place on you for you
to put together your favorite I spent
some time with it and I you know
couldn't put the two together I I admit
that I could spend more time on it but
you've got some
I guess more Junior lawyers that could
probably figure it out between the two
sides yes I'm not trying to add a burden
I just
okay James do you be can you be in
charge of artificial verdict form
tonight
okay if you want if you want to email it
as soon as you guys agree on something
then maybe I can have a heads up before
we meet tomorrow
okay the only other alternative Mr Owens
is
um I guess to recess
after the evidence and to take the time
to get it hammered out and we'll have to
do that if we can't agree before them
before tomorrow so could we both get a
final count too on on time yeah so both
sides would like that excellent point
give me just a minute here I'll get that
put together
I want to beat the rush down the hill
here
hang out I'll be right done with it
foreign
thank you